ALL RIGHT. THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON PUBLIC SAFETY, UH, IS
BEGINNING. UH, WE HAVE WE ARE
MEETING IN ROOM. 2200 IN THE
1021 Ó STREET BUILDING. UH, WE
HAVE 13 BILLS ON THE CALENDAR
WITH THREE THAT ARE ON CONSENT.
S¼ B 1005 AJ R EIGHT AND S¼ B
1122. I ALSO WANNA HIGHLIGHT
THAT S¼ B 922 BY SENATOR ROTH
AND S¼ B 1160 BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO ARE POLLED FROM
TODAY'S AGENDA. UM, I WOULD LIKE
TO CALL ROLL. MOHAB HERE. WAHAB
HERE. SEYARTO SARTO HERE.
BRADFORD BRADFORD HERE, SKINNER
WIENER. THANK YOU. SO WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED QUORUM. UH, WE CAN
START WITH OUR VERY FIRST BILL
BY SENATOR ROTH S¼ B 902. AND
JUST AGAIN TO HIGHLIGHT TO THE
PUBLIC AND FOLKS, WE WILL BE
HAVING WITNESSES TESTIFY FOR TWO
MINUTES AT THAT LECTERN, UM BOTH
OPPOSITION AND SUPPORT. WE WILL
ALSO ASK ME TOO, TO SPEAK AT
THAT LECTERN. UM YOU KNOW, STATE
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION,
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE,
AND WE LIKE TO MOVE THROUGH THIS
PRETTY QUICKLY. UM SENATOR ROSS,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MADAM. CHAIR MEMBERS,
SENATE BILL 902 WILL ADD AN
AUTOMATIC TENURE. FIREARMS
PROHIBITION TO MISDEMEANOR
ANIMAL ABUSE. ACTIONS. AS YOU
KNOW, CALIFORNIA HAS LED THE
COUNTRY IN ENSURING THAT
FIREARMS DO NOT FALL INTO THE
HANDS OF THOSE WHO HAVE
DEMONSTRATED. DOCUMENTED
DEMONSTRATIONS OF VIOLENT
TENDENCIES IN AN ATTEMPT TO
PREVENT FUTURE VIOLENCE AGAINST
OTHERS. GIVEN THE NUMEROUS
STUDIES SHOWING AN ANIMAL ABUSE
IS A PREDICTOR OF VIOLENCE
AGAINST HUMANS. CALIFORNIA NEEDS
TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE WITH A
DOCUMENTED HISTORY OF ANIMAL
ABUSE ARE PROHIBITED FROM OWNING
AND POSSESSING FIREARMS FOR 10
YEARS. THERE ARE CURRENTLY 50
MISDEMEANOR CHARGES THAT UPON
CONVICTION LEAD TO A 10 YEAR
PROHIBITION. THESE CRIMES ARE
GENERALLY RELATED TO FIREARMS,
BUT ALSO INCLUDES ENDANGERING
THE HEALTH OF A CHILD AND
ENDANGERING THE HEALTH OF AN
ELDER OR DEPENDENT ADULT.
CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY
RECOGNIZED THAT ENDANGERMENT OF
A CHILD OR ELDER IS GROUNDS FOR
A FIREARM PROHIBITION AND GIVEN
THE LINK BETWEEN ANIMAL ABUSE
AND INCREASED LIKELIHOOD OF
INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE, INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE. IT IS
APPROPRIATE THAT THE STATE ALSO
INSTITUTE A FIREARM PROHIBITION
FOR THOSE CONVICTED OF ANIMAL
ABUSE AS WELL. OUR OFFICE HAS
BEEN ENGAGED WITH THOSE IN
SUPPORT AND IN OPPOSITION, AND
WE'VE TAKEN AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE
THE FELONY FOR NON COMPLIANCE
WITH THE FIREARMS PROHIBITION
AND ALSO TO LIMIT THE PENALTY TO
A MISDEMEANOR. HAVE ALSO
ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO LIMIT THE SCOPE OF
THIS BILL TO ONLY MISDEMEANORS
CHARGED UNDER PENAL CODE 597 A,
WHICH IS THE MORE SERIOUS ANIMAL
CRUELTY CHARGE. I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND
THE STAKEHOLDERS WHO HELPED ME
IMPROVE THIS BILL WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF THE BILL
AS RIVERSIDE COUNTY DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY, MEGAN HOLMAN.
MEGAN, YOU WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS MEG HOLMAN,
AND I'M, A DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
COUNTLESS STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
THAT THERE IS A LINK BETWEEN
VIOLENCE TOWARD ANIMALS AND
VIOLENCE TOWARD HUMANS.
UNFORTUNATELY STATISTICALLY,
THOSE THAT COMMIT ACTS OF
VIOLENCE AGAINST ANIMALS ARE
LIKELY TO GO ON TO HURT PEOPLE.
IT IS A CRIME TO ABUSE ANIMALS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA PENAL
CODE SECTION 597 A APPLIES TO
THE MOST EGREGIOUS FORMS OF
ANIMAL ABUSE. THOSE CONVICTED
UNDER THIS SECTION HAVE TAKEN
AFFIRMATIVE STEPS TOWARD HARMING
AN ANIMAL AND OF ULTIMATELY
CAUSED AN INJURY. IT DOES NOT
APPLY TO THOSE WHO NEGLECT AN
ANIMAL. IN SHORT, 597 A
ENCOMPASSES JUST THE PRECISELY
THE BEHAVIOR THAT HAS BEEN FOUND
TO BE A PREDICTOR FOR VIOLENCE
AGAINST PEOPLE. NATIONWIDE GUN
VIOLENCE IS AT AN ALL TIME HIGH.
MASS SHOOTINGS ARE BECOMING ALL
TOO COMMON AND GUNS ARE BECOMING
MORE PREVALENT IN ALL KINDS OF
CRIMES, INCLUDING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
THESE POTENTIALLY LETHAL WEAPONS
ARE NOT READILY AVAILABLE TO
THOSE WHO SEEK TO HURT OTHERS.
AS THE SENATOR INDICATED.
CALIFORNIA HAS LONG LED THE WAY
IN SEEKING TO KEEP GUNS OUT OF
THE HANDS OF THOSE WITH
DEMONSTRATED VIOLENT TENDENCIES.
BALANCE ARE PROHIBITED FROM
POSSESSING FIREARMS. HOWEVER
UNDER CURRENT LAW, AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO HURTS AN ANIMAL AND IS
CONVICTED OF A MISDEMEANOR CAN
LAWFULLY ACCESS AND POSSESS A
GUN AS SOON AS THEY'RE OFF
PROBATION IN CALIFORNIA,
MISDEMEANOR PROBATION IS ONLY
ONE YEAR. THIS MEANS THAT AN
ANIMAL ABUSER CAN LAWFULLY
ACCESS A GUN SHORTLY AFTER THEY
ARE CONVICTED AND WELL BEFORE
THEY'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MEANINGFULLY ADDRESS THEIR
BEHAVIOR. THE PURPOSE OF THIS
BILL IS TO ENSURE THAT THOSE WHO
HAVE ACTED TO HURT ANIMALS ARE
NOT ABLE TO LAWFULLY ACQUIRE OR
POSSESS A GUN FOR 10 YEARS.
IDEALLY THIS WILL ALLOW AMPLE
TIME FOR REFLECTION AND TO
CORRECT WHATEVER IT IS THAT LED
TO THE VIOLENT CONDUCT IN THE
FIRST PLACE. S¼ B 902 IS A STEP
TOWARD SAFER COMMUNITIES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. DO YOU HAVE
ANOTHER WITNESS? NÓ MADAM CHAIR.
OK THANK YOU. WE WOULD LIKE TO
ASK FOR THOSE THAT SUPPORT IN ME
TOO. STATE YOUR NAME YOUR ORG
AND THAT YOU SUPPORT HØI
NICHOLAS SACKETT FOR SOCIAL
COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANKS. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SOSA MADDEN AT W
STRATEGIES HERE ON BEHALF OF
ANIMAL LEGAL DEFENSE FUND WITH
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. WE ARE
NOW IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. IVY
FITZPATRICK, CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE ANY OTHER SUPPORTERS,
SAYING NONE WILL MOVE ON TO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. NÓ
OPPOSITION, ALL RIGHT, WE'LL
MOVE ON TO OPPOSITIONS IN THE
ROOM. SING NAN WILL MOVE THE
COMMENTARY TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. SEE NÓ COMMENTARY
SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
VOTE. THANK YOU. UM, DO WE HAVE
A MOTION? MOVED BY SENATOR
BRADFORD YES. OH, MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB SEYARTO
RTO I, BRADFORD BRADFORD I.
SKINNER WIENER. THAT BILL IS ON
CALL. THANK YOU, SENATOR. YOU
CAN NOW PRESENT YOUR SECOND BILL
S¼ B 921. THANK YOU, MADAM.
CHAIR THIS BILL. IT'S AN ANIMAL
ABUSE BILL. IT SEEKS TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE WHO AFFIRMATIVELY
SEEK TO CAUSE HARM TO ANIMALS OR
HELD ACCOUNTABLE REGARDLESS OF
THEIR RELATIONSHIP TO THE ANIMAL
, IN OTHER WORDS, REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER THEY OWN IT OR DON'T OWN
IT OR HAVE CUSTODY OF IT, OR
DON'T OR THE SEVERITY OF THE
INJURY THAT THEY INFLICT. IT
CLOSES AN UNINTENDED LOOPHOLE IN
OUR LAWS, AS YOU WILL HEAR FROM
THE TESTIMONY FROM MY LOCAL
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. IT'S
DIFFICULT, OFTEN DIFFICULT FOR
PROSECUTORS TO CHARGE ABUSERS
WHEN THE ABUSER DOES NOT OWN THE
ANIMAL. THE ISSUE OF OWNERSHIP
APPLIES PARTICULARLY IN
SCENARIOS INVOLVING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. AS YOU CAN IMAGINE,
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OFTEN INVOLVES
VIOLENT PARTNERS, KICKING,
PUNCHING OR OTHERWISE ATTACKING
THE PET OF THEIR SIGNIFICANT
OTHER, THOUGH THESE ATTACKS ARE
TRAUMATIC INJURIES TO THE PET
RARELY REACH THE LEVEL OF
MAIMING, MUTILATING OR TORTURING
, THAT IS CURRENTLY REQUIRED TO
CHARGE NON OWNERS WITH ANIMAL
CRUELTY. THIS BILL WILL CHANGE
THAT BY CREATING PARITY IN THE
LAW TO TREAT ALL MALICIOUS
BEHAVIOR TOWARD ANIMALS EQUALLY
SPECIFICALLY, THIS BILL ADDS
THAT ANYONE WHO SUBJECTS A
LIVING ANIMAL TO NEEDLESS
SUFFERING MAY BE CHARGED FOR
ANIMAL CRUELTY IN THE SECTION
THAT DOES NOT REQUIRE OWNERSHIP.
PENAL CODE SECTION 597, A MY
OFFICE HAS WORKED WITH COUNTLESS
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT THIS
BILL TARGETS THE RIGHT PEOPLE. I
HAVE ACCEPTED THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED BY THE A èC
LU AND PUBLIC DEFENDERS. IT IS
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THESE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE AMENDED INTO
THE BILL BEFORE IT IS SENT BACK
TO THE SENATE DESK FOR REFERRAL
TO THE NEXT COMMITTEE. I'D LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND
THE STAKEHOLDERS THROUGH THIS
RATHER TORTURED PROCESS ALL OF
WHOM HELPED ME AND HELPED MY
OFFICE IMPROVE THIS BILL WITH ME
TO ONCE AGAIN TESTIFY ON BEHALF
OF THIS PARTICULAR BILL. IS
RIVERSIDE COUNTY DISTRICT DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY MEGAN HOLMAN.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN, MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. AGAIN MY NAME IS
MEG HOLMAN, AND I'M, A DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. ANIMALS ARE SOME OF OUR
SOCIETY'S MOST VULNERABLE
VICTIMS BECAUSE THEY CANNOT
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES. THEY ARE
HELPLESS TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
FROM ABUSE, AND THEY RELY ON US
TO LOVE AND CARE FOR THEM. THEY
ALSO RELY ON US TO SPEAK UP ON
THEIR BEHALF. UNFORTUNATELY
THERE ARE PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO
WILL CHOOSE TO HURT THEM FOR ONE
REASON OR ANOTHER, OR FOR NÓ
REASON AT ALL. ANIMAL ABUSE IS A
CRIME IN CALIFORNIA, AND IT'S
GENERALLY DIVIDED INTO TWO
CATEGORIES. AFFIRMATIVE CONDUCT
INTENDED TO CAUSE SERIOUS INJURY
OR CRIMINAL NEGLECT OF AN
ANIMAL. UNDERSTANDABLY THERE IS
A POSSESSORY INTEREST THAT IS
REQUIRED TO BE CHARGED WITH
NEGLECT. HOWEVER THERE IS
CURRENTLY A LOOPHOLE IN THE LAW.
THAT LEAVES PROSECUTORS UNABLE
TO SEEK JUSTICE IF AN INDIVIDUAL
INFLICTS SUFFERING ON AN ANIMAL
THAT DOES NOT BELONG TO THEM SO
LONG AS THAT INDIVIDUAL DOES NOT
ENGAGE IN CONDUCT THAT AMOUNTS
TO MAIMING, MUTILATING,
TORTURING OR KILLING IN OTHER
WORDS, ABSENT A REALLY SERIOUS
INJURY. THERE'S NOT MUCH WE CAN
REALLY DO. TO PROSECUTE. IN FACT
, IT'S ACTUALLY CURRENTLY LEGAL
TO HERD AN ANIMAL THAT YOU DON'T
OWN SO LONG AS THE INJURY IS NOT
SEVERE. AS A SENATOR NOTED
ANIMAL ABUSE OCCURS WITH SOME
FREQUENCY IN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SITUATIONS. A DOMESTIC ABUSER
MAY TARGET THEIR VICTIM'S PET BY
PUNCHING THEM KICKING THEM,
ETCETERA, UH, BUT UNLESS THEY
BREAK A BONE OR CAUSE A REALLY
EGREGIOUS INJURY, THERE'S
NOTHING LEGALLY THAT CAN BE DONE
TO HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE. COMMON
SENSE SAYS THIS WAS NOT WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE INTENDED WHEN
ORIGINALLY ENACTING PENAL CODE
SECTION 597. S¼ B 921 SEEKS TO
CLOSE THE EXISTING LOOPHOLE TO
PROVIDE PROTECTION FOR ALL
ANIMALS, REGARDLESS OF, UH YOUR
POSSESSORY INTEREST. IT WILL
ENSURE THAT JUSTICE CAN BE
ACHIEVED WHEN OUR FURRY FRIENDS
ARE SUBJECTED TO NEEDLESS
SUFFERING. SO WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. DO YOU
HAVE A SECOND WITNESS? I DO NOT.
I'M SURE. ALL RIGHT. WE WILL GO
ON TO ME, TOO IN SUPPORT. UH,
NICHOLAS SACKETT FOR SOCIAL
COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION. WE
ARE IN SUPPORT IN, UH, THEORY OF
THE BILL. THE INTENT OF THE BILL
. WE HAVE SOME ISSUES WITH THE
EXCEPTIONS, WHICH WE WILL BE
COMMUNICATING WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE AS IT'S MOVED FORWARD.
THANK YOU. THIN MADINA, A W
STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF ANIMAL
LEGAL DEFENSE FUND. I'D LIKE TO
FOLLOW UP ON THE COMMENTS BY MY
COLLEAGUE AT SOCIAL COMPASSION.
WE'VE SHARED SOME CONCERNS WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THEM. BUT WE ARE SUPPORTIVE
IN CONCEPT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. IVY FITZPATRICK, CALIFORNIA
DAS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK
YOU. WE HAVE ANYBODY ELSE SEEING
NONE. WE'LL MOVE ON TO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. OPPOSITION
BECCA KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF OF
A èC LU CALIFORNIA ACTION,
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR AND HIS
OFFICE'S WILLINGNESS TO WORK
WITH US TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS.
THANK YOU. LESLIE CALDWELL,
HOUSTON, CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE. WE ARE
ASSOCIATION. WE ARE GRATEFUL TO
THE SENATOR AND STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US AND WE WITHDRAW
OUR OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE ANYBODY ELSE IN BETWEENERS,
ME TOOS, SEEING NONE. WE'LL MOVE
THE CONVERSATION BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. UH WHEN WE
HAVE A MOTION, UH, SENATOR,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN I VOTE AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU AND THE MEMBERS FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. DEFINITELY UM SO
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR SEO.
CAN WE CALL A ROLL CALL VOTE.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WYE IR TO I.
BRADFORD BRADFORD I SKINNER
WIENER BILLS ON CALL. UM AND WE
CAN MOVE ON TO S¼ B 922 SENATORS
FULL SORRY. LET'S LET'S MAKE THE
CHAIR I. I EVEN ANNOUNCED IT
RIGHT. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. OK WE HAVE
SENATOR ASHBY. SO ALL RIGHT. UM
DO WE HAVE A MOTION FOR THE
CONSENT ITEMS? UH, SENATOR
BRADFORD HAS MOVED OR CONSENT
ITEMS. B 1005 AND S¼ 122 AJ R AJ
R AJ R EIGHT W W AYS ART TO SAY
OUR TOE I BRADFORD BRADFORD I
SKINNER WIENER. CONSENT ON CALL.
ALL RIGHT, SENATOR ASHBY, UH,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT S¼ B
1035? YES THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. GOOD MORNING. THANKS FOR
STARTING EARLY SO WE COULD KNOCK
SOME OF THESE OUT. IT'S REALLY
HELPFUL TO THE REST OF THE DAY.
I APPRECIATE IT. I'M HERE TO
PRESENT S¼ B 1035, WHICH SEEKS
TO REFORM THE STRUCTURE OF
RESTITUTION PAYMENTS.
RESTITUTION FINES ARE PAID TO
THE VICTIM'S COMPENSATION BOARD,
WHICH YOU KNOW BY INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE CONVICTED OF CRIMES.
IT'S AN ATTEMPT TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE FINANCIAL
LOSSES THAT THEY'VE CAUSED TO
THEIR VICTIMS. RESTITUTION IN
THEORY AIMS TO SERVE AS A FORM
OF RESTORATIVE JUSTICE BY
PROMOTING FORGIVENESS,
RESOLUTION OF DAMAGES AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. HOWEVER
RESTITUTION FINES IN ACTUAL
PRACTICE HAVE OFTENTIMES FAILED
TO MAKE ANY OR ALL PARTIES WHOLE
VICTIM RESTITUTION CAN EASILY
EXCEED AMOUNTS IN THE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS ON TOP OF
WHICH THEY ACCRUE INTEREST FROM
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD ADD UP
TO A 10% RATE. CURRENTLY 80% OF
THE PEOPLE WHO OWE RESTITUTION
LIVE IN POVERTY AND AT A 10%
INTEREST RATE, FURTHER
EXASPERATING AND ALREADY DIRE
SITUATION. S¼ B 1035 SEEKS TO
REFORM THE RESTITUTION PROCESS
TO ENSURE THAT VICTIMS ARE
PROPERLY COMPENSATED BY REDUCING
THE INTEREST RATES ON
RESTITUTION PAYMENTS, ALLOWING
FOR INCREASED FLEXIBILITY BY
REQUIRING RESTITUTION PAYMENTS
BE PAID BEFORE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS TO THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD AND
IMPLEMENTING A SLIDING SCALE. SB
1035 SEEKS TO REFORM THE
STRUCTURE OF RESTITUTION
PAYMENTS BY BETTER ENSURING
VICTIMS ARE COMPENSATED IN A
TIMELY MANNER AND EASING THE
BURDEN FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING
TO REINTEGRATE BACK INTO THEIR
COMMUNITIES HELP THEM PAY OFF
THEIR DEBT. AND MOVE FORWARD
WITH PRODUCTIVE LIVES. SOME OF
OUR SUPPORT INCLUDES THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION. THEY ARE
CO SPONSOR, CALIFORNIA STATE
TREASURER WHO'S HERE TO SPEAK TO
THIS TODAY THE LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN
SISTER WARRIORS PROGRAM, THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE, CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
SECURE JUSTICE AND MADAM CHAIR.
MY TWO LEAD WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
TODAY ARE, UH, APRIL FROM THE
SISTER WARRIORS AND OUR STATE
TREASURER FIONA MÀ. THANK YOU.
UM AGAIN. WITNESSES ONLY HAVE
TWO MINUTES. SO WHO'S YOUR FIRST
WITNESS? LET'S START WITH OUR
STATE TREASURER. SO TREASURE
FIONA MÀ WELCOME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, UH, TO
SENATOR ASHBY AND HER STAFF AND
EVERYBODY WHO IS SUPPORTING OUR
BILL. MY LAST TWO BILLS SIGNED
BY GOVERNOR BROWN. WHEN I LEFT
THE LEGISLATURE WAS TO ALLOW
WOMEN CONVICTED OF LIFE WITHOUT
PAROLE A SECOND CHANCE AT, UM AT
HEARING THEIR CASE UNDER THE
BATTERED WOMEN'S SYNDROME, SO I
HAVE BEEN ACTIVE WITH THIS
COMMUNITY AND FEEL VERY STRONGLY
AND COSPONSORING THIS INITIATIVE
BECAUSE THIS BILL BECAUSE, LIKE
SENATOR ASHBY SAID,
APPROXIMATELY 80% OF OWING
RESTITUTION OR LIVING IN POVERTY
AND UNABLE TO PAY THEIR DEBT.
THIS INABILITY TO PAY OFF THE
RESTITUTION DEBT CAN ALSO LEAD
TO HIGHER CASES OF RECIDIVISM
AND SO REDUCING THESE BARRIERS
TO PAYMENTS WILL HELP. NOT ONLY
THE VICTIMS MAKE SURE THAT MORE
MONEY GETS INTO THEIR POCKET BUT
ALSO HELP. UH THE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ASSIMILATE
WITHOUT HAVING THIS HUGE DEBT
LOOMING OVER THEIR HEADS FOR
LIFE. UM UNLIKE OTHER DEBT
RESTITUTION, HAS NÓ STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS AND IS NOT
DISCHARGEABLE IN BANKRUPTCY. SO
CONSEQUENTLY, THIS DEBT CAN
FOLLOW THESE FORMALLY
INCARCERATED. FOLKS FOR LIFE
WHICH YOU KNOW IS VERY
DETRIMENTAL TO THEM BEING ABLE
TO ASSIMILATE AND GET BACK INTO
MAINSTREAM SOCIETY. SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT SPEAKER, TWO
MINUTES. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE. TODAY. I STAND BEFORE
YOU TO DISCUSS A MATTER OF
FAIRNESS AND FINANCIAL EQUITY
WITHIN OUR LEGAL SYSTEM.
SPECIFICALLY THE METHOD BY WHICH
WE IMPOSE AND COLLECT
RESTITUTION. I ASK YOU TO
CONSIDER THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
LOWER INTEREST. AND AN ABILITY
TO PAY STYLE OF GARNISHMENT AS
THE MOST EQUITABLE APPROACH. 24
JUSTICES SERVED WITHOUT CAUSING
UNDUE FINANCIAL STRAIN ON
INDIVIDUALS. CURRENT GARNISHMENT
PRACTICES OFTEN FOLLOW A ONE
SIZE FIT ALL APPROACH,
DISREGARDING ADAPTORS ACTUAL
ABILITY TO PAY. THIS CAN LEAD TO
CATASTROPHIC OUTCOMES WHERE
INDIVIDUALS ARE PUSHED INTO
DEEPER FINANCIAL DISTRESS.
SOMETIMES EVEN RESULTING IN
POVERTY OR HOMELESSNESS.
FINANCIAL DISTRESS POVERTY. I'M
SORRY, IS A PUNITIVE CYCLE THAT
BENEFITS NÓ ONE, NOT THE
CREDITOR, NOT THE STATE, AND
CERTAINLY NOT THE INDIVIDUAL AND
THEIR FAMILIES, WHO ARE
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET. AN
ABILITY TO PAY MODEL. ON THE
OTHER HAND, ASSESSES INDIVIDUALS
FINANCIAL SITUATION, INCLUDING
INCOME, ESSENTIAL LIVING AND
SPACE, A LIVING EXPENSES AND
EXISTING DEBTS BEFORE
DETERMINING TO A FAIR AMOUNT.
EXCUSE ME, I'M REALLY NERVOUS
THAT CAN BE GARNISHED. THIS
METHOD ENSURES THAT RESTITUTION
IS PAID IN A MANNER THAT IS
PROPORTIONATE TO THE
INDIVIDUAL'S FINANCIAL
CAPABILITY. THEREBY UPHOLDING
THE PRINCIPLE OF JUSTICE WHILE
PREVENTING FURTHER HARM TO THOSE
ALREADY FACING FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES. ADOPTING THIS MODEL
NOT ONLY SUPPORTS THE FINANCIAL
STABILITY OF INDIVIDUALS BUT
ALSO ENHANCES THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF RESTITUTION COLLECTION.
STUDIES IN PILOT PROGRAMS IN
VARIOUS JURISDICTIONS HAVE SHOWN
THAT WHEN PAYMENTS ARE SET AT
REASONABLE LEVELS, COMPLIANCE
INCREASES, PEOPLE ARE MORE
LIKELY TO PAY WHAT THEY OWE WHEN
THEY FEEL THE SYSTEM TREATS THEM
FAIRLY WHEN THE PAYMENTS DO NOT
THREATEN THEIR BASIC SURVIVAL.
MOREOVER INSTITUTING AN ABILITY
TO PAY GARNISHMENT AND MODEL
ALIGNS WITH BROADER SOCIETAL
VALUES OF COMPASSION, EQUITY AND
REHABILITATION, IT ACKNOWLEDGES
THAT WHILE INDIVIDUALS MUST BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
ACTIONS, THE PUNISHMENT SHOULD
NOT EXTEND TO PERPETUATING A
CYCLE OF POVERTY. IT SUPPORTS
THE INTEGRATION OF INDIVIDUALS
INTO SOCIETY AS PRODUCTIVE
CONTRIBUTING MEMBERS RATHER THAN
PUSHING THEM TO THE MARGINS. IN
CONCLUSION. I URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER THE LONG TERM BENEFITS
OF TRANSITIONING TO AN ABILITY
TO PAY MODEL OF GARNISHMENT.
THIS APPROACH NOT ONLY ENSURES
THAT RESTITUTION PAYMENTS ARE
MADE IN FAIR AND EQUITABLE
MANNERS BUT ALSO PROMOTE THANK
YOU AND I WANT TO SAY MY NAME IS
APRIL, GRAY SAID. I'M THE POLICY
MANAGER FOR SISTER WARRIORS. AND
I FAILED TO MENTION THAT IN THE
BEGINNING. THANK YOU. NÓ. I
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. UM DO WE HAVE ANY? ME TOO?
IN SUPPORT AGAINST STATE? YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND THAT
YOU SUPPORT THE BILL. LESLIE
CALDWELL. HOUSTON CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AS FOR
NUNEZ, ON BEHALF OF THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION AND STRONG
SUPPORT BARBARA CHÁVEZ WITH THE
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
AND WILL SUPPORT COL. LANDS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
WOMEN, PRISONERS AND SUPPORT
MAIL HERE ON BEHALF OF LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN, PD COSPONSOR AND FULL
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ELISA BIERA
WOULD SURVIVE AND PUNISHED WITH
STRONG SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT. DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER SUPPORT? S¼ NAN
WILL MOVE ON TO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. DO WE SEE ANY
OPPOSITION LEAD OPPOSITION? I
DON'T SEE ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT. SO YOU GET TWO
MINUTES IF YOU IF YOU NEED I
WON'T TAKE TWO MINUTES OF YOUR
TIME. UH, GOOD MORNING. IVY
FITZPATRICK, CALIFORNIA Dð, A S¼
ASSOCIATION, UM IN OPPOSITION.
VICTIM RESTITUTION IN THIS STATE
IS BOTH A CONSTITUTIONAL AND A
STATUTORY, RIGHT? UM
UNFORTUNATELY, AND I'VE SEEN
THIS THROUGH MY 25 YEARS HERE.
MANY OFFENDERS NEVER PAY VICTIM
RESTITUTION IN FULL OR REALLY
ANY AT ALL. AND THE VICTIMS
NEVER REALIZED THOSE RIGHTS. UM
WITH THE COST OF LIVING, ALWAYS
RISING, ESPECIALLY IN THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS, AND OFFENDERS
FAILING TO PAY THAT RESTITUTION,
IF ANY, MOST NOT IN FULL EVER.
REDUCING THE INTEREST RATE TO 1.
UM PRETTY MUCH ENSURES THAT
CRIME VICTIMS WILL NEVER BE MADE
WHOLE. UM AND THOSE IMPORTANT
CONSTITUTIONAL AND STATUTORY
RIGHTS WILL NEVER BE REALIZED
FOR THEM. SO èC G A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NÓ
VOTE. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER OPPOSITION WITNESSES? DO
WE HAVE ANY OTHER? ME TOO? IN
OPPOSITION, SEEING NONE. WE CAN
MOVE THE CONVERSATION TO THE
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
SENATOR SIERRA I HAVE A QUESTION
IN YOUR BILL ABOUT INCENTIVIZING
BECAUSE WE TALK ABOUT THE 80%
THAT MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO AFFORD
A 10% INTEREST RATE. BUT YOU
TALK ABOUT A SLIDING SCALE. UM
WHAT'S THE OTHER 20? AND ALSO ON
THE OTHER 80% THERE'S TWO
QUESTIONS IN HERE. THE OTHER 80%
HOW DO THEY DETERMINE? UM WHAT?
THEIR, UM WHAT THEIR INCOME
REALLY IS, BECAUSE THERE'S
SEVERAL WAYS OF MAKING INCOME
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE ENGAGE IN
AND A LOT OF IT IS NOT REPORTED.
SO HOW DO THEY ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE HAVE AN INCENTIVE TO PAY
THE RESTITUTION? WHICH IS THAT
LARGE 10. VERSUS A 1. THAT YOU
WOULD, UM YOU KNOW IF I IF YOU
HAVE A LOW INTEREST RATE ON YOUR
HOUSE, YOU DON'T SELL YOUR HOUSE
BECAUSE NOW BECAUSE THAT MONEY
CAN BE USED FOR SOMETHING ELSE,
SURE. A HIGHER FINANCIAL PEOPLE.
WE'LL TAKE THE 1% INTEREST AND
NEVER EVER PAY. UH, BECAUSE THEY
CAN USE THAT MONEY FOR OTHER
STUFF. SO HOW DO WE INCENT? HOW
DO WE CONTINUE TO INCENTIVIZE
PEOPLE TO PAY THE RESTITUTION
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY,
THERE'S A REASON THEY'RE PAYING
RESTITUTION. IS THAT BECAUSE
THEY VICTIMIZE SOMEBODY? SURE.
SO JUST THERE'S A LOT OF
QUESTIONS WRAPPED UP IN YOUR
QUESTION. LET ME SEE IF I CAN
ADDRESS SOME OF THEM. FIRST OF
ALL, I WANNA BE REALLY CLEAR.
THIS DOESN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT
CHANGING A PERSON'S OBLIGATION
TO PAY RESTITUTION DOESN'T
CHANGE THAT AT ALL. IT DOES
PRIORITIZE OF THE RESTITUTION
PAID WHAT GETS PAID FIRST. IN
OTHER WORDS, WE'RE GONNA PAY THE
VICTIMS FIRST, BEFORE WE PAY THE
GOVERNMENT AND THE OTHER THING
THAT IT DOES IS JUST REMOVE THAT
10% INTEREST RATE. I WOULD NOT.
I WOULD ARGUE THAT THE PERCENT
INTEREST RATE IS NOT SOME
INCENTIVE TO PAY. UH NOR WOULD A
1% INTEREST RATE BE AN INCENTIVE
TO PAY PEOPLE WHO ARE PAYING
RESTITUTION BECAUSE OF
INCARCERATION ARE GENERALLY ON
SOME KIND OF PROBATION OR PAROLE
AS WELL. PAYING RESTITUTION IS
GENERALLY A PART OF THAT, UH
PAROLE OR PROBATION. THEY HAVE
MANY REASONS TO PAY THEIR
RESTITUTION IN FULL WAY BEYOND
AN INTEREST RATE, WHICH IS IN
MANY WAYS NOT THE BIGGEST
CONCERN, BECAUSE AS YOU CAN SEE,
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
FIGHTING FOR THEIR EVERYDAY
EXISTENCE. WHAT A 10% INTEREST
RATE DOES IS MAKE THE
RESTITUTION HARDER TO PAY MORE
DIFFICULT TO PAY. IF INSTEAD OF
OWING YOU A DOLLAR, I OWE YOU A
DOLLAR AND 10 CENTS, AND EVERY
MONTH THAT GOES UP. IT GETS
HARDER AND HARDER FOR ME TO PAY
THAT DEBT TO YOU, SO THIS MAKES
IT FOR PEOPLE WHO WANT TO PAY
THIS RESTITUTION TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT, AS TO THE SLIDING SCALE
THAT YOU ASKED ABOUT. IT'S
EXACTLY AS IT SOUNDS. IT GIVES
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH EACH
INDIVIDUAL PERSON ON A SLIDING
SCALE THAT THAT TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT WHAT THEY'RE ABLE TO PAY
. SOME PEOPLE MAKE MORE MONEY
DURING PARTICULAR SEASONS. SOME
PEOPLE DON'T SOME PEOPLE ARE IN
SCHOOL. SOME PEOPLE JUST LIKE
YOU WOULD DO WITH SCHOOL LOANS
LIKE WE DO WITH STUDENTS. IT
GIVES THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE A SLIDING SCALE. WHERE THEY
GET HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
INDIVIDUALIZE A PLAN THAT BETTER
GIVES THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO PAY
THEIR RESTITUTION PAYMENTS. I
WOULD ACTUALLY ARGUE THAT THE
OPPOSITION'S ARGUMENT THE Dð A
S¼ ARGUMENT WOULD BE THE BEST
ARGUMENT TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
WHICH IS TO SAY THAT YOU REALLY
WANT THE VICTIMS TO GET THE
MONEY, THEN TAKE THE 10%
INTEREST RATE OFF OF IT AND LET
THEM PAY THE MONEY THAT THEY
HAVE TO THE VICTIMS. THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL DOES. RIGHT, BUT WHEN
THEY'RE MAKING INSTALLMENT
PAYMENTS OR TAKING A LONG TIME
TO PAY, JUST THE THEY DO THAT,
ANYWAY, THAT'S ALREADY THE EVEN
THE AMOUNT THAT THAT VICTIM
LOSES THEIR ABILITY TO TAKE THAT
MONEY AND VICTIM LOSES. NOTHING
HERE. VICTIM LOSES NOTHING
VICTIM HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ACTUALLY GET MONEY WHERE THEY
WEREN'T GETTING IT BEFORE,
BECAUSE THEY GET IN PRIORITY
ORDER, YOU KNOW, IN LOANS.
THERE'S A PRIORITY ORDER LIKE
WHEN YOU GET A LIEN, YOU WANT TO
KNOW WHERE AM I ON MY LIEN IN MY
SECOND OR THIRD IN ORDER. THIS
MOVES PAYMENT ABOVE INTEREST
RATES. SO THIS IS GOOD FOR
VICTIMS AND GOOD FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE PAYING RESTITUTION. MAKE NÓ
MISTAKE ABOUT THAT. WELL, MAYBE
SHOULD HAVE SOMETHING. WHERE
THE, UM THE STATE OR WHOEVER THE
AGENCY IS THAT YEAH FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD HOLDS THAT 10% OR
WHATEVER IT IS AND ACCORDING TO
AND ONCE THAT'S PAID, THEY CAN
DECIDE HOW MUCH THAT VICTIM CAN
PAY INTO FOR THE INTEREST RATE,
BECAUSE SOMEHOW WE CANNOT I. I
DON'T WANNA DISINCENTIVIZE
PEOPLE PAYING, UH, THE VICTIM
BECAUSE THE VICTIM IS THE ONE
WHO IS, UH AND I DON'T THINK
THIS BILL DOES THAT, BUT I DO. I
APPRECIATE THE CONCERN. THANK
YOU, SENATOR SKINNER. UM YES. I
MOVED THE BILL. AND UH, JUST,
UM, APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
BRINGING IT THE REDUCTION OF THE
INTEREST RATE IS GOING TO
BENEFIT THE ABILITY TO COLLECT.
IT'S GOING TO HELP OUR VICTIM
SERVICES BECAUSE RIGHT NOW, WITH
THE INTEREST RATE WE CHARGE,
WE'RE NOT EVEN COLLECTING THESE
RESTITUTIONS. SO THIS IS SMART.
NOT ONLY FOR, UH, ASSISTING THE
IMPACT ON THE LOWER INCOME
PERSON, BUT ALSO GUARANTEEING
THAT WE CAN COLLECT THESE FUNDS.
SO WITH THAT I MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE SENATOR? URGE. AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND PATIENCE. THANK YOU.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR SKINNER. CAN WE CALL A
ROLL CALL VOTE. MOTION IS DUE
PASS TO REVIN TAX WAH WAH I SAY
TO OUR TO NOW, BRADFORD SKINNER.
I WIENER. THAT BILL IS ON CALL
SENATOR. THANK YOU. GOOD JOB.
ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE SENATOR
MENJIVAR PRESENTING S¼ B 169. TO
THIS PICTURE. MHM. AND JUST FOR
THOSE THAT ARE JOINING US. I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT AGAIN THAT
WITNESSES SPEAK AT THAT LECTERN.
YOU WILL BE, UM, YOU KNOW?
CHECKS FOR ABOUT TWO MINUTES.
AND THEN UM, ALSO ME, TOOS
SENATOR WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU, MA'AM. CHAIR GOOD
MORNING, UH, PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. I'M HERE TO TALK
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS WHEN AN
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUAL GETS
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED AND THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO
BRING DOWN JUST, UM,
DETERMINATIONS OF THE SAME
PEOPLE THAT ARE PEERS WITH THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO CAUSES THAT HARM.
CURRENTLY IF AN INCARCERATED
PERSON IS A VICTIM OF SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT BY AN EMPLOYEE, THE
ALLEGATION INVESTIGATION UNIT OF
CALI, CALIFORNIA'S OF
CORRECTIONS IN REHAB OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS IS THE SOLE
ENTITY LAING. THE INVESTIGATIONS
PROCESS OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
ALLEGATIONS AND COMPLAINTS.
FOLLOWING THE BEST INVESTIGATION
WARDENS HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
REVIEW COMPLETED MISCONDUCT
INVESTIGATION REPORTS AND
DETERMINE THE DISPOSITION OF THE
INVESTIGATION, INCLUDING
FINDINGS AND CORRECTIVE OR
DISCIPLINE DISCIPLINARY ACTION.
THIS PROCESS ESSENTIALLY
ENTRUSTS èC Dð èC R TO OVERSEE
ITSELF ACTING AS THE JUDGE, THE
JURY AND THE ARBITER OF
PUNISHMENT OVER ITS OWN
EMPLOYEES. SB 1069 WILL WORK TO
PROTECT INCARCERATED VICTIMS OF
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT BY STAFF OF
èC Dð èC R. DECADES OF SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT, INCLUDING RECENT
EVENTS AT THE CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
WOMEN'S FACILITY AND THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTION FOR WOMEN
HAVE DEMONSTRATED THAT A NEW
PROCESS FOR SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
CASES AND COMPLAINTS IS
NECESSARY. RECENTLY A JANUARY
REPORT FROM THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL ALSO FOUND THE
èC Dð èC R S¼ VIOLATED ITS OWN
REGULATIONS BY DOWNGRADING STAFF
AND MISCONDUCT COMPLAINTS TO
ROUTINE GRIEVANCES. AS WE 1069.
WE WILL CREATE A MEANINGFUL
PATHWAY FOR VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT BY èC Dð èC R STAFF
TO REPORT INCIDENTS OF SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT WITH THE ASSURANCE
THAT MULTIPLE STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING ONE INDEPENDENT OF
èC, Dð èC R WILL DETERMINE THE
OUTCOMES IN INVESTIGATION.
BREAKING IT DOWN. SPECIFICALLY
THIS BILL WOULD DO THREE THINGS.
IT WOULD REQUIRE RIG TO MONITOR
ALL SEXUAL MISCONDUCT CASES IN
COMPLAINTS INVOLVING STAFF. IT
WILL GIVE OIG INVESTOR AUTHORITY
OVER SEXUAL MISCONDUCT INVOLVING
STAFF, AND IT WILL MAKE THE
OUTCOME OF STAFF INVESTIGATIONS
DECIDED AS A SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY BETWEEN THE
WARDED AND THE Ó IG. IF IN SOME
CASES THERE IS SIGNIFICANT
DISAGREEMENT BETWEEN THE Ó IG
AND THE WARDEN, THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE CAN BE NOTED, WILL BE
NOTIFIED AND HAS THE AUTHORITY
TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS TO èC
Dð èC R TO THAT, MADAM CHAIR.
I'D LIKE TO NOW TURN OVER TO TWO
WITNESSES TO SPEAK ON THE NEED
FOR S¼ B 1069. THANK YOU. UM CAN
WE HAVE OUR FIRST WITNESS
APPROACH THE LECTERN? LIKE TO
WELCOME UP NIKKI CAROL, THE
DIRECTLY IMPACTED SURVIVOR. AND
THEN YOU HAVE A SECOND WITNESS
AS WELL. UM JENNY HWANG, AN
ATTORNEY AT JUSTICE FIRST
PERFECT. EACH OF YOU WILL HAVE
TWO MINUTES. UM GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. UM, I
AM NIKKI CARROLL. AT THE AGE OF
17. I WAS SENTENCED TO PRISON
AND I SERVED 20 YEARS GOING TO
PRISON AT 17. I WAS SCARED AND
NAIVE, WHICH MADE ME EASIER,
WHICH MADE IT EASIER FOR
OFFICERS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF ME
. I WAS TOLD THAT OFFICERS WERE
SUPPOSED TO HELP US. I MET AN
OFFICER WHO WAS NICE TO ME. BUT
HE HAD ULTERIOR MOTIVES. HE
GROOMED ME AND THEN BEGAN
SEXUALLY ASSAULTING ME. UM AFTER
IT BECAME KNOWN I WAS BLAMED FOR
THE ABUSE BY STOP, AND NOBODY
HELPED. THEY PUT ME IN FRONT OF
A CAMERA AND INTERROGATED ME IT
WAS ALL MALE STAFF, AND I WAS
NEVER OFFERED ANY MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT. WHETHER I COOPERATED OR
NOT, I KNEW THEY WOULD PLACE ME
IN ADMINISTRATIVE SEGREGATION. I
WAS SCARED OF RETALIATION,
INCLUDING WHEN IT WENT UP FOR
PAROLE. I WAS SCARED OF BEING
SHIPPED FURTHER FROM MY FAMILY,
WHICH IS WHAT THEY EVENTUALLY
DID. I DIDN'T HAVE ANY SAFE
OPTIONS. I FELT HELPLESS. AND I
WASN'T THE ONLY VICTIM TREATED
LIKE THIS AND THEIR EYES. THEY
GOT RID OF THE PROBLEM, WHICH
WAS ALWAYS US, AND OUR ABUSERS
KEPT THEIR JOBS. I HAVE NÓ TRUST
IN èC Dð èC R'S INVESTIGATION
PROCESS, AND IT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE FOR WORDS TO HAVE THE
FINAL SAY, BECAUSE THEY WILL
PROTECT THEMSELVES IF A VICTIM
APPEALS TO èC Dð èC R,
SACRAMENTO THEY CHECK BACK IN
WITH THE PRISONS INVESTIGATIVE
SERVICES UNIT, SO IT'S A
CIRCULAR PROCESS WITH NÓ
OVERSIGHT. SOMEHOW IT'S BECOME
èC Dð C'S POLICY TO BLAME THE
VICTIM. THIS IS HOW THEY
DEHUMANIZE US THAT IT'S OUR
FAULT, THEN WE MUST HAVE SEDUCED
THEM THAT THE OFFICERS ARE JUST
WEAK AND CAN'T HELP IT. THEY
KEEP ABUSING US AND BLAMING US
FOR THE ABUSE BECAUSE THEY KNOW
THEY'LL GET AWAY WITH IT. èC Dð
èC R IS INVESTIGATION PROCESS
IS NOT ONLY FAILING VICTIMS BUT
CAUSING MORE HARM. IT'S ALSO
SILENCING VICTIMS, WHICH ALLOWS
OFFICERS TO SEXUALLY ASSAULT
MORE PEOPLE. AND THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENED IN MY CASE, ALLOWING
HIM TO ABUSE SO MANY MORE WOMEN.
WE NEED OVERSIGHT AND A REASON
TO TRUST THE VICTIMS THAT
VICTIMS WILL BE PROTECTED. AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SV 169. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. YOU WILL ALSO HAVE
TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS JENNY HUANG.
I'M A CIVIL RIGHTS ATTORNEY WITH
OVER 20 YEARS OF EXPERIENCE AND
PRISON SEXUAL ABUSE STAFF CASES
I'M TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF 10
AND SIX S¼ B 1069 BECAUSE IT'S
WHAT'S NEEDED TO TAKE EXCLUSIVE
AUTHORITY AWAY FROM PRISON
WARDENS AND DECIDING THE
FINDINGS IN DISCIPLINARY
RESPONSE TO STAFF SEX ABUSE. FOR
DECADES, PRISONS HAVE SWEPT
UNDER THE RUG COMPLAINTS OF
STAFF SEX MISCONDUCT AGAINST
THEIR OWN. STAFF AND PRISON
WARDENS HAVE PARTICIPATED IN IN
AUTHORIZE THIS PRACTICE, FOR
EXAMPLE, IN ONE CASE, A PRISON
WARDEN FOUND A CLAIM OF SEX
MISCONDUCT TO BE UNSUBSTANTIATED
DESPITE HANDWRIT LETTERS FROM
PRISON STAFF EXPLICITLY ASKING
FOR SEX FAVORS THAT WERE
VALIDATED BY A HANDWRITING
EXPERT. IN ANOTHER CASE, A
SERGEANT WAS ACCUSED OF HAVING
INTERCOURSE UP TO THREE TIMES
PER WEEK WITH AN INCARCERATED
PERSON AND THE WARDEN SUSTAINED
SIX ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF.
MISCONDUCT HOWEVER, AFTER A
YEARLONG INVESTIGATION DURING
WHICH THE SERGEANT WAS PUT ON
PAID ADMINISTRATIVE LEAVE, THE
WARDEN ALLOWED THE SERGEANT TO
RESIGN WITHOUT ANY DISCIPLINARY
ACTION. S¼ B 169 REMEDIES ARE
REMAINING FLAW OF A DEPARTMENTAL
PRACTICE THAT ALLOWED PRISONS TO
SWEEP UNDER THE RUG. ANY
COMPLAINTS OF MISCONDUCT AGAINST
THE PRISON'S OWN STAFF BY TAKING
AWAY THE EXCLUSIVE AUTHORITY
FROM THE WARDEN TO MAKE FINDINGS
AND TAKE DISCIPLINARY ACTION
AGAINST HER? ON HIS OR HER OWN
PRISON STAFF. THIS BILL REMOVES
THE POTENTIAL FOR BIAS BY MAKING
IT A SHARED DECISION BETWEEN THE
WARDEN AND THE OIG. THIS BILL
ALSO GIVES THE OIG INVESTIGATIVE
AUTHORITY OVER ALL SEX
MISCONDUCT COMPLAINTS AGAINST
STAFF WITH THE RECENT EXPOSURE
OF RAMPANT SEXUAL ABUSE IN
CALIFORNIA'S PRISONS, THE CDCR
HAS DEMONSTRATED THAT IT
REQUIRES EXTERNAL OVERSIGHT TO
ENSURE THAT THE STAFF AND
INVESTIGATION PROCESS IS FREE OF
BIAS AND THAT APPROPRIATE ACTION
IS TAKEN AGAINST PRISON STAFF
WHO ENGAGE IN SEXUAL ABUSE. THIS
BILL IS A CRITICAL STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION BECAUSE IT MOVE
THE Ó A S¼ ROLE BEYOND MERE
MONITORING ASSESSMENT AND
REPORTING ON CDC'S FAILURES TO
ONE OF INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATION
AND RECOMMENDATION IN CASES
WHERE INTERVENTION IS WARRANTED.
THANK YOU RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. UH, DO WE
HAVE ANY SUPPORT ME TOO? PLEASE?
STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND THAT YOU
SUPPORT IT. WE LIKE TO MOVE
THROUGH THIS PRETTY QUICKLY. SO
IF YOU GUYS CAN LINE UP, UM AT
THAT LECTERN THANK YOU. GRAYSON
SISTER WEAR OF FREEDOM OF
COALITION PROUD COSPONSOR OF
THIS BILL. ERIN FRIDAY AND I
HOPE THIS BILL WILL ALSO HELP
WOMEN WHO ARE BEING SEXUALLY
ABUSED BY MEN WHO THINK THEY ARE
WOMEN. THANK YOU. MARGIE LEE
SAMPSON, ADVISOR ON BEHALF OF
FAMILIES TO GET SOME MANDATORY
MINIMUMS, OTHERWISE KNOWN AS FAM
AND STRONG SUPPORT. I DON'T WANT
THAT. SO FOR KENNETH HARTMAN,
TRANSFORMATIVE PROGRAMMING WORKS
AND ALSO IN FOR GRIP TRAINING
INSTITUTE. WE'RE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. LESLIE
CALDWELL, HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION, AND FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING,
GLENN BACKUS FOR INITIATE
JUSTICE AND LAWYERS COMMITTEE
FOR CIVIL RIGHTS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, HE ONLY
MAGGIE LAD HERE ON BEHALF OF
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN AND ALL OF US ARE
NONE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. UM CAPRI WALKER ON BEHALF
OF THE ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
IN SUPPORT. BARBARA CHÁVEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE ELLA BAKER CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS AND STRONG
SUPPORT. BOBBY LANDS PROUD
COSPONSOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WOMEN, PRISONERS
FOR ALL CIS WOMEN AND ALL TRANS
PEOPLE. THANK YOU. DR LISA BIERA
WOULD SURVIVED AND PUNISHED AND
STRONG SUPPORT FOR ALL
SURVIVORS. èC ON BEHALF OF
VALOR. U S¼ PROUD, COSPONSOR AND
IN SUPPORT. PEGGY DELGADO, FAVA
BRIDGE NETWORKS STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES? SEEING
NONE. DO WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IN THIS ROOM THAT
WOULD JUST LIKE TO STATE THAT
THEY ARE OPPOSING OUR RIGHT. WE
WILL BRING THE CONVERSATION BACK
TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS, SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU, UM SENATOR.
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THIS BILL. IT'S VERY NEEDED. UM
THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS.
IT VISITED ONE OF OUR WOMEN'S
FACILITIES, AND IT WAS THE
FACILITY WHERE ONE OF THE
CORRECTIONS OFFICIALS HAD
PREVIOUSLY BEEN CHARGED BY A Dð
A WITH MORE THAN 90 COUNTS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT ON A MINIMUM OF
17 OF THE INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS IN THAT FACILITY,
AND IT HAD BEEN GOING ON FOR
YEARS. SO IT'S UM UNFORTUNATE
THAT THIS HAS CONTINUED, AND
IT'S CLEAR THAT WE NEED A BETTER
SYSTEM AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR BRINGING IT FORWARD AND I'M
HAPPY TO MOVE IT. SENATORS. ALL
RIGHT. I TOO WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL BECAUSE
IT DOES ADDRESS ONE OF THE ONE
OF THE ISSUES THAT WE'RE HAVING
WITH SOME OF OUR PRISONS AND,
FRANKLY, THE CONDITIONS THAT UH,
SOME OF THOSE PRISONS ARE ARE
SOME OF OUR INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS ARE BEING SUBJECTED
TO WHILE THEY'RE IN PRISON. UM
BUT THE WORK IS NOT DONE. THERE
IS, I THINK A LOT MORE IS ONE OF
THE WITNESSES HAS STATED, WE
NEED TO ADDRESS SOME OF THESE
OTHER ISSUES BESIDES THIS ONE,
AND SO I LOOK FORWARD TO HOPING,
HOPING THAT YOU WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON ON THIS. I THINK YOU AND
I HAD A VERY SHORT CONVERSATION
ON THE FLOOR ONE DAY ABOUT THIS.
AND I SAID, HEY, DO SOME
LEGISLATION. WE'LL BE RIGHT
THERE WITH YOU. UM BECAUSE THERE
IS NÓ REASON TO DEHUMANIZE
PEOPLE THAT ARE INCARCERATED.
AND SO I APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THE BILL AND LOOK FORWARD TO
MORE THAT THAT WORK ON THIS
ISSUE WITH A COUPLE OF OUR
PRISONS IN PARTICULAR. THANK
YOU. SENATOR I JUST WANNA THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD. I PERSONALLY HAVE
VISITED CHILLA, UH, IN THE PAST,
AND I KNOW THAT THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS ALSO VISITED IT AGAIN.
UM, I DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
WE DO HAVE A PROBLEM IN OUR
PRISONS, BOTH MALE AND FEMALE
FACILITIES. UM, I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. UM AND AT THE SAME
TIME, I ALSO WANT TO ENSURE THAT
THE PUBLIC UNDERSTANDS THAT
PRISON GUARDS HAVE A JOB. AND
ANY TIME THAT THEY ARE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF SOMEBODY THAT THEY
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR. THEY ARE,
UH, VIOLATING THAT TRUST THAT
SAFETY COMPONENT AND MUCH MORE.
UM AND FRANKLY, FOR THOSE THAT
ARE, YOU KNOW, HIDING AND
DENYING AND COVERING UP FOR
THEIR COLLEAGUES OR THEMSELVES
AND SO FORTH. IT'S A COMPLETE
DERELICTION OF DUTY. AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THIS FORWARD. I THINK THAT WE
OBVIOUSLY HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF WORK LEFT. TO DO? UM
BUT I BELIEVE THAT SENATOR
SKINNER MOVED THE BILL. AND
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. YOU KNOW,
SENATOR SKINNER, THIS THIS
LEGISLATION CAME OUT OF THAT
VISIT THAT WE DID A COUPLE
MONTHS AGO. AND MY, UH, CREATING
THAT RELATIONSHIP WITH SISTER
WARRIORS AND SO MANY OTHER
ENTITIES THAT ARE LOOKING TO
REPRESENT AND BRING TO LIGHT THE
VOICES OF INDIVIDUALS THAT
SOMETIMES ARE SUPPRESSED. BUT
THIS ALSO REMINDED ME OF MY TIME
IN THE MILITARY. WHERE IT'S
ABOUT VERY SIMILAR KIND OF
APPROACHES, WHERE PEOPLE IN
UNIFORM WE TEND TO PROTECT OUR
OWN AND IN THE MILITARY FOR
DECADES, WE HAD THE ISSUE WHERE
IF, UM MY FELLOW SISTER OF MINE
IN UNIFORM WAS SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED. IT WAS OUR
SUPERVISORS WHO WOULD
INVESTIGATE. AND WAS OUR
COMMANDING OFFICERS WHO WOULD
THEN HAVE TO DECIDE IF THEY
WANTED A REPRIMAND THEIR FRIEND
OR NOT, AND IN MOST CASES, THEY
NEVER DID. UH, THAT SAME THING
IS WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE IN OUR
PRISONS, WHICH IS WHY IT WAS
PERSONAL TO ME BECAUSE WE WANNA
MAKE SURE UH, THAT ALL UNIFORMED
OFFICERS, ALL UNIFORMED
PERSONNEL ARE ONLY AREN'T ONLY
THERE. TO PROTECT THEIR OWN
PEERS ARE ALSO THERE TO DO THEIR
JOB LIKE MANAGER SAID. AND I I'D
BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T MENTION
THAT. I DO NOT AGREE WITH ONE OF
THE COMMENTS THAT HE SAID OUT OF
THE SUPPORT HERE, UM GENDER
IDENTITY. BEING TRANSGENDER HAS
NOTHING TO DO. IT'S NOT
CORRELATED. TO SEXUAL ASSAULT.
SO UH, SENATOR SARTO. I AGREE
WITH THE FIRST HALF OF YOUR
COMMENTS, BUT, UH, DO NOT
DISAGREE WITH THE SECOND HALF. I
DON'T THINK WE NEED TO DO
ANYTHING MORE AND THAT IN THAT
SPACE, UH, THERE IS NÓ
CORRELATION WITH SOMEONE'S
IDENTITY AND SEXUAL ASSAULT. SO
WITH THAT RESPECT, WE ASK FOR AN
I VOTE. THANK YOU, UH, THE BILL
WAS MOVED BY SENATOR SKINNER.
UH, CAN WE GET A ROLL CALL VOTE,
PLEASE. 1069 MOTION IS DUE PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB WAHAB,
I SEAR. AYE, SEYARTO I BRADFORD.
SKINNER SKINNER, I WIENER
WIENER. I SENATOR THAT BUILDS ON
CALL. THANK YOU. UH, CAN WE HAVE
SENATOR MIN SENATOR MIN IS GOING
TO BE PRESENTING SB 1242. RIGHT?
AS SOON AS SHE SAID MEN AND
RAISE THEIR HAND. THE SENATOR OF
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
UH, GOOD MORNING TO YOU ALL, UH,
AS PART OF THE SENATE SAFER
CALIFORNIA PLAN, S¼ B 1242 WOULD
SPECIFY THAT FOR THE CRIME OF
RECKLESS ARSON, THE FACT THAT
THE OFFENSE WAS CARRIED OUT WITH
A MERCHANT'S PREMISE PREMISES IN
ORDER TO FACILITATE ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT SHALL BE A FACTOR
IN AGGRAVATION AT SENTENCING.
WE'RE ALL ACUTELY AWARE OF THE
FACT THAT RETAIL THEFT IS
GROWING AND BECOMING
INCREASINGLY SOPHISTICATED IN
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THIS STATE TO
FACILITATE ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT. UH, MANY HAVE RESORTED TO
ARSON, SETTING FIRE AS A
DISTRACTION FROM THE THEFT THAT
IS OCCURRING WHILE STAFF ARE
DISTRACTED THIS DANGEROUS,
DIVERSE AND ENDANGER LIVES AND
DISRUPTS BUSINESS OPERATIONS
STORES NOT ONLY LOSE THE STOLEN
MERCHANDISE BUT MAY SUFFER
DAMAGE TO THEIR BUILDINGS AND
MERCHANDISE, SOMETIMES HAVING IT
CLOSED FOR WEEKS TO MAKE REPAIRS
TO DETER THIS SB 1242 WOULD
IMPOSE HIGHER PENALTIES AND
CRACK DOWN ON THE CRIMINALS WHO
COMMIT THESE HEINOUS CRIMES.
TODAY I HAVE WITH ME RACHEL
MICHELIN PRESIDENT AND èC E Ó
OF THE CALIFORNIA RETAIL
ASSOCIATION'S RETAILERS
ASSOCIATIONS TO TESTIFY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
, RACHEL, MICHELIN PRESIDENT AND
èC E Ó OF THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION. I'M HERE
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL 1242 LET ME SHARE A
FEW EXAMPLES OF WHY THIS
LEGISLATION IS NEEDED LAST
SEPTEMBER IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
, A 40 YEAR OLD WOMAN WAS TAKEN
INTO CUSTODY IN CONNECTION WITH
THE FIRE AT A POPULAR RETAILER,
WHERE SHE SET FIRE TO A BABY
CLOTHES SECTION OF THE STORE.
ACCORDING TO THE INVESTIGATION,
THE FIRE WAS INTENTIONALLY SET
TO COVER AN ATTEMPT TO STEAL THE
FIRE CAUSED $500,000 IN DAMAGE
TO THE BUILDING AND $1 MILLION
IN DAMAGE TO PRODUCT IN JUNE OF
2020, THREE HERE IN SACRAMENTO,
WHILE SHOPPERS WERE IN THE STORE
, A FIRE WAS SET INSIDE A
RETAILER AS A DISTRACTION, WHILE
A CAREFULLY ORCHESTRATED TEAM
WALKED OUT WITH HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS WORTH OF MERCHANDISE.
THE FIRE FORCE THE STORE TO
CLOSE FOR WEEKS DUE TO DAMAGE
AND TO RESTOCK THE PRODUCTS.
ARSON WITHIN RETAIL
ESTABLISHMENTS POSES A THEIR
THREAT NOT ONLY TO PROPERTY BUT
ALSO TO HUMAN LIFE. THESE
ESTABLISHMENTS ARE NOT JUST
BUILDINGS. THEY ARE HUBS OF
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY WHERE
INDIVIDUALS EARN THEIR
LIVELIHOODS AND COMMUNITIES
GATHER WHERE, WHEN ARSON STRIKES
, THE CONSEQUENCES RIPPLE FAR
BEYOND THE PHYSICAL DAMAGE THE
ECONOMIC REPERCUSSIONS OF ARSON
WITHIN RETAIL STORES ARE
SIGNIFICANT SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS WHO ARE THE BACKBONE OF
OUR ECONOMY, INVEST THEIR TIME
RESOURCES AND PASSION INTO THEIR
ESTABLISHMENTS. WHEN THESE
BUSINESS FALL VICTIM TO ARSON.
IT NOT ONLY RESULTS IN FINANCIAL
LOSS BUT DISRUPTS THE LOCAL
ECONOMY, LEADING TO JOB LOSSES
AND DECLINE IN COMMUNITY MORALE.
BY ENACTING LEGISLATION TO
INCREASE PENALTIES FOR ARSON.
WITHIN RETAIL STORES. WE SEND A
CLEAR MESSAGE THAT SUCH CRIMES
WILL NOT BE TOLERATED. STRONGER
PENALTIES SERVE AS A DETERRENT
TO POTENTIAL OFFENDERS AND HELP
PROTECT BOTH PROPERTY AND HUMAN
LIFE. I URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL 1242. THANK YOU. NÓ.
OK THANK YOU. UM CAN WE HAVE OUR
ME TOO? WITNESSES COME UP IF WE
HAVE ANY STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION THAT YOU SUPPORT.
ALL SHORT, MADAM CHAIR MEMBER IS
JOVO ON BEHALF OF THE LEAD
CALIFORNIA CITY IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHERS SEEING NONE WILL MOVE
ON TO LEAD OPPOSITION. DO WE
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION THAT WOULD
LIKE TO STATE THEIR OPPOSED? S¼
NONE WILL MOVE THE CONVERSATION
TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SEEING NONE. UM SORRY,
SENATOR SKINNER. I MOVED THE
BILL. THANK YOU, SENATOR. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? IT'S A BARN
BURNER. CLEARLY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR EYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
SKINNER. CAN WE CALL ROLL? S¼ P
1242 MOTION IS DUE PASS DUE.
APPROPRIATIONS WAH WAH I SEAR
TOTO I BRADFORD SKINNER, I
SKINNER I WIENER THAT BILL IS ON
CALL SENATOR. THANK YOU. SENATOR
GONZALEZ HIDDEN IN THE BACK. OK?
SENATOR GONZALEZ. YOU WILL BE
PRESENTING SB 1250 THREE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. I'D LIKE TO BEGIN
BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO EXTEND THE 60 DAY
GRACE PERIOD FOR FIREARMS SAFETY
CERTIFICATE RENEWAL TO 120 DAYS
AND I'M HERE TO PRESENT TODAY S¼
B 125 THREE, WHICH WILL MAKE
ESSENTIAL UPDATES TO THE FIREARM
SAFETY CERTIFICATE PROGRAM TO
KEEP CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES SAFE
. CALIFORNIA HAS MADE GREAT
STRIDES IN RECENT DECADES TO
REDUCE GUN VIOLENCE, HOWEVER.
DENTAL AND UNINTENTIONAL
SHOOTINGS CONTINUE TO BE A
LEADING CAUSE OF FIREARM RELATED
INCIDENTS IN THE STATE,
PARTICULARLY FOR CHILDREN
CONTRIBUTING TO ROUGHLY 30% OF
ALL FIREARM RELATED DEATHS AND
INJURIES FROM 2016 TO 2022. S¼ B
1250 THREE WILL CLOSE THIS
LOOPHOLE AND INCREASE FIREARM
SAFETY BY REQUIRING FIREARM
OWNERS TO RENEW THEIR SAFETY
CERTIFICATE EVERY FIVE YEARS, AS
OPPOSED TO A ONE TIME
CERTIFICATE AT THE POINT OF SALE
AS REQUIRED UNDER CURRENT LAW.
THIS WILL ALSO ENSURE THAT
FIREARM OWNERS ARE UP TO DATE ON
FIREARM SAFETY LAWS AND BEST
PRACTICES, INCLUDING SAFE
STORAGE AND HANDLING. TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT. TODAY I HAVE REBECCA
MARQUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER PROTECTION POLICY
CENTER AT THE UNIVERSITY OF SAN
DIEGO SCHOOL OF LAW, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK I VOTE ON SB
1253 YOU HAVE ONE WITNESS.
CORRECT ONLY ONE SENATOR. OK UH,
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
REBECCA MARCUS, REPRESENTING THE
CONSUMER PROTECTION POLICY
CENTER AT THE UNIVERSITY OF SAN
DIEGO SCHOOL OF LAW. èC PP èC
IS A NONPROFIT, NONPARTISAN
ACADEMIC CENTER OF RESEARCH,
TEACHING, LEARNING AND ADVOCACY
AND REGULATORY AND PUBLIC
INTEREST LAW FROM 2016 TO 2021.
THERE WERE CLOSE TO 70,000
GUNSHOT WOUND INCIDENTS THAT
RESULTED IN DEATH OR REQUIRED
URGENT MEDICAL ATTENTION. 45.
PERCENT WERE THE RESULT OF
SELF-HARM EITHER AN ACCIDENT OR
AN ACT OF SUICIDE OF THE 15%
THAT WERE THE RESULT OF
INTENTIONAL SELF HARM. THERE WAS
A 91% FATALITY RATE. AS THE DATA
SHOWS. THERE ARE MANY WAYS IN
WHICH CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES ARE
IMPACTED BY GUN VIOLENCE. NOT
ALL LEGISLATIVE BILLS TO COMBAT
GUN VIOLENCE SHOULD FOCUS ON
TARGETING CRIMINAL CRIMINALS OR
ILLEGAL FIREARMS. STRATEGIC
LEGISLATION SHOULD BE USED TO
HELP REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
UNNECESSARY DEATHS AND INJURIES
THAT IMPACT OUR COMMUNITIES. F
S¼, èC S¼, OR FIREARM SAFETY
CERTIFICATES WERE SO EVERY
FIREARM OWNER COULD UNDERSTAND
AND FOLLOW FIREARMS SAFETY
PRACTICES. THE FSC TEST REQUIRES
THE APPLICANT TO BE PROVIDED
WITH INFORMATION REGARDING
RESPONSIBLE HANDLING AND
SECURING THE FIRE OWNER'S
FIREARM, PROPER TRANSFER OF A
FIREARM AND SUICIDE PREVENTION.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES A PERSON
PERSON TO ACQUIRE THIS FSC
BEFORE THE PURCHASE OR RECEPTION
OF ANY FIREARM. WITH EXCEPTIONS,
HOWEVER, THERE IS NÓ REQUIREMENT
FOR A FIREARM OWNER TO RECERTIFY
THAT FIREARM SAFETY CERTIFICATE
AFTER ITS EXPIRATION FURTHER.
THERE IS NÓ REQUIREMENT FOR A
PERSON WHO BRINGS THE FIREARM
OUTSIDE THE STATE FROM OUTSIDE
THE STATE. AS YOU KNOW, THE BODY
PASSES NUMEROUS LAWS EACH YEAR
RELATED TO GUN SAFETY AND
VIOLENCE PREVENTION. WE SHOULD
MAKE SURE GUN OWNERS ARE
EDUCATED ON THEM. ADDITIONALLY
THOSE IMPORTING FROM OUT OF
STATE THANK YOU. OK THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR I VOTE. DEFINITELY UM
APPRECIATE IT. UH, WE'LL MOVE ON
TO ME TOO, AND SUPPORT AND I'D
LIKE TO GIVE A ME TOO, ON BEHALF
OF BRADY CAMPAIGN AND BRADY,
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. UM SEEING ANY OTHER ME TOOS
. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL MOVE ON TO
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES. YOU
WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS RICK
TRAVIS, THE LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION. SB 1250 THREE,
SEEKS TO TAKE A LONG CHAIN OF
HANDSET GUN SAFETY CERTIFICATES
AND FF èC S¼ INTO WHAT APPEARS
TO BE A LICENSE. ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS WITH THAT IS LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS ONLY HAD TO GET
ONE OF THOSE IF YOU WERE
PURCHASING A FIREARM, THE FACT
IS, THERE ARE MILLIONS OF LAW
ABIDING CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE
NEVER HAD TO GO THROUGH THAT
PROCESS, AND THEREFORE THERE IS
NOT REALLY A MECHANISM TO REACH
OUT TO THOSE PEOPLE THAT WHEN
THIS GOES INTO EFFECT, THEY WILL
ESSENTIALLY BECOME NON LAW
ABIDING FIREARMS OWNERS BECAUSE
OUR OWN DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
DOESN'T EVEN KNOW HOW MANY
FIREARMS ARE IN THE STATE.
SECONDLY, UM LAWFUL GUN OWNERS
WHO LAWFULLY DO HAVE THOSE
CERTIFICATES ARE OFTEN GOING
THROUGH TRAINING OVER AND OVER.
SO IT SEEMS TO ISSUE ISN'T WITH
THE LAW ABIDING GUN OWNER THAT'S
GOING TO GUN STORES AND GOING
THROUGH TRAIN. BUT GETTING TO
THOSE PEOPLE WHO AREN'T THAT
SOMETHING THAT ALL OF OUR
ORGANIZATIONS ARE WORKING ON.
AND YET WE HAVE HAD NÓ ONE IN
THIS BODY COME TO US AS A
STAKEHOLDER AND SAY, HOW DO WE
IMPROVE THAT? THE THIRD ISSUE
THAT I SEE IS WE HAVE MIGRATORY
POPULATIONS THAT THE COURTS HERE
IN THIS COUNTRY HAVE NOW SAID
ARE ALLOWED TO POSSESS FIREARMS.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO REACH OUT TO
THOSE MIGRATORY POPULATIONS AND
ADVISE THEM BECAUSE WE DON'T
EVEN KNOW WHO THEY ARE? AND
WHICH ONES THAT HAVE IT SO
RESPECTFULLY? FOR ALL THESE
REASONS I DON'T SEE COVERED IN
THIS BILL. WE ASK FOR A NÓ VOTE.
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE A SECOND?
YES UM, YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES AS
YOU KNOW. I APPRECIATE THE TWO
MINUTES. MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE SAM PERETTI IS
REPRESENTING GUN OWNERS OF
CALIFORNIA. I'D LIKE TO POINT
OUT A COUPLE OF THINGS.
CALIFORNIA IS 20% OF EVERYTHING
IN AMERICA. BUT EVEN IF WE JUST
TAKE HALF OF WHAT? CALIFORNIA IS
REPRESENTING THE NUMBER OF GUNS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT 50 MILLION
GUNS IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
NOW YOU ARE ASKING THESE LAWFUL
GUN OWNERS. TO IN ESSENCE
LICENSE THE FACT THAT THEY ARE
EXERCISING AN ENUMERATED
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT? CLEARLY
THIS AFFECTS THEIR SECOND
AMENDMENT RIGHTS. THEREFORE THE
SUPREME COURT SAYS THAT YOU HAVE
TO SHOW A HISTORICAL ANALOG
GOING TO 1791 TO SHOW THAT THERE
IS SOME SORT OF RELATIONSHIP TO
THIS MEASURE THAT IS BEING
PASSED. THERE IS NONE. THERE ARE
NONE. SO ON ON ITS ON ITS BASIS,
THIS BECOMES A LICENSE BECAUSE
YOU CANNOT LEGALLY OWN A GUN
UNLESS YOU HAVE THIS FIREARM
SAFETY CERTIFICATE THAT'S
UNCONSTITUTIONAL. ACCORDING TO
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA,
DAVIS. THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY
50 FIREARM DEATHS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF
ACCIDENTS BECAUSE OF SAFETY
VIOLATIONS OR NEGLIGENCE. OUT OF
50 MILLION THAT WELL AGAIN,
ACCORDING TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA, DAVIS THAT
CONSTITUTES 0.001. OF THE
LEGALLY OWNED GUNS OUT THERE.
THAT ARE USED IN AN ACCIDENT
THAT LEADS TO DEATH. THAT IS A
VERY, VERY, VERY, VERY SMALL
PERCENTAGE. OF PEOPLE. OF GUNS
THAT HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN ONE
OF THESE ACCIDENTS. THIS IS A AN
ATTEMPT TO WATER MOSQUITO WITH A
NUCLEAR BOMB. BY REQUIRING
LAWFUL CITIZENS WHO ARE
EXERCISING THEIR SECOND
AMENDMENT RIGHTS AND DENYING
THEM THE ABILITY TO DO THAT. BY
REQUIRING THEM TO HAVE A
LICENSE. AND IF THEY DON'T HAVE
THIS LICENSE THEY CAN'T EXERCISE
THAT RIGHT TIME. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. APPRECIATE IT. WE GAVE YOU
A COUPLE MORE SECONDS. JUST YES.
SO UM, DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION, PLEASE? STATE YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND THAT
YOU OPPOSE GREG HERNER ON BEHALF
OF THE 10 CHAPTERS OF SAFARI
CLUB INTERNATIONAL IN CALIFORNIA
IN OPPOSITION. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MARK KENLEY WITH
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL. WE HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL'S IMPACT
ON LICENSED HUNTERS WHO USE
HANDGUNS. AND SO WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING LIEUTENANT
JULIA DE LEÓN IN OPPOSITION ON
BEHALF OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SHERIFF CHAD BIANCO. GOOD
MORNING, KAYLEIGH HOPKINS, STATE
DIRECTOR FOR THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION, HERE TODAY IN
OPPOSITION. ALEX BOSKY OF GUN
OWNERS OF CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
OPPOSITION. OH KING. CITRUS
HEIGHTS, CALIFORNIA STRONG
OPPOSITION. DEBORAH KING CITRUS,
HES STRONG OPPOSITION. ELIZABETH
ROSEMARY, I'M A TWO TIME VIOLENT
CRIME SURVIVOR AS CCW. OLDER AND
I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHERS IN THE ROOM, SAYING NONE
WILL MOVE THE CONVERSATION TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. DO WE HAVE ANY COMMENTARY,
SAYING NONE. SENATOR SKINNER
MOVED THE BILL. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
? JUST WANNA THANK YOU FOR, UH,
THE COMMENTARY BOTH ON SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR I VOTE. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
SKINNER. CAN WE GET A ROLL? CALL
VOTE, PLEASE. S¼ P 1 253 MOTION
IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WILL SEAR SEAR
NOW, BRADFORD. HØI SKINNER EYE
WIENER. SENATOR THAT BILLS ON
CALL. UM WE WILL MOVE ON TO
SENATOR SARDO, UM, PRESENTING S¼
B 1219. MARJORIE.
RIGHT SENATOR. YOU HAVE THE
FLOOR. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
HONORABLE CHAIR. I'M HERE TO
PRESENT S¼ B 1 1219. THIS BILL
MAKES THE ACT OF IMPEDING
TRAFFIC AND LOITERING IN A
PUBLIC PLACE WITH THE INTENT TO
DIRECT OR SOLICIT PROSTITUTION
FORMS OF DISORDERLY CONDUCT. SB
1219 IS MEANT TO ADDRESS THE
INCREASE IN HUMAN TRAFFICKING
WHILE SHIELDING OUR MOST
VULNERABLE, UH, WITH ME HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT S¼ B 1219 ARE
ARE MY LEAD WITNESSES ARE OPEL
SINGLETON AND MARJORIE SAYLOR.
OPEL HAS YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
DEALING WITH HUMAN TRAFFICKING,
AND MARJORIE IS BOTH A SURVIVOR
OF THE SEX, TRAFFIC INDUSTRY AND
HUMAN TRAFFICKING, WHO NOW
ADVOCATES ON BEHALF OF VICTIMS
AND SURVIVORS. YES. YOU WILL
HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I WANT TO SHARE
DESI'S STORY WITH YOU. SHE WAS A
BEAUTIFUL MEXICAN AMERICAN WOMAN
WHO CAME TO ME SEEKING HELP
WHILE ENGAGED IN STREET
PROSTITUTION. SHE WANTED A WAY
OUT AND NEEDED TREATMENT FOR
UNTREATED HÌ. I VÆ WITHIN OUR
FIRST TWO WEEKS IN SHELTER. SHE
WAS HOSPITALIZED THREE TIMES
AFTER ATTEMPTING SUICIDE. SHE
WAS STRUGGLING TO ACCEPT HER
DIAGNOSIS IN EVERY FORM OF
SUPPORT SYSTEM HAD ABANDONED HER
. EVEN WITH THE TEMPORARY
HOUSING. SHE LEFT THE SHELTER
AND WENT BACK HOME TO SAN
FRANCISCO. SHE CALLED ME TO
THANK ME FOR EVERYTHING I'D DONE
FOR HER AND SAID GOODBYE. DESI
TOOK HER LIFE THAT DAY. I AM
MARJORIE SAYLOR, AND I AM ALSO A
SURVIVOR OF THE SEX INDUSTRY AND
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. I, TOO,
NEARLY LOST MY LIFE TO THE SEX
INDUSTRY TWICE LONG BEFORE MY
WORK BEGAN IN THE SPACE AS AN
ADVOCATE IN 2014. I HAVE
ASSISTED THOUSANDS OF SURVIVORS
ACROSS THE U S¼ WITH EMERGENCY
SHELTER. OVER THE LAST 11 YEARS.
I'VE ASSISTED. I HAVE ALSO A
LONG HISTORY AS A PROGRAM
DIRECTOR OF ANOTHER NONPROFIT
AND AS AN EDUCATOR IN MY
COMMUNITY BEFORE MAKING MY
CAREER CHANGE RECENTLY TO THE
Dð, A S¼ OFFICE IN SAN DIEGO,
I'VE SEEN NOTHING SHORT OF THE
GRIM REALITIES OF WHO BENEFITS
THE MOST FROM LEGISLATION THAT
ALLOWS NÓ PROTECTIONS AGAINST
PERPETRATORS OF ABUSE AND
SYSTEMS OF PROSTITUTION. I HAVE
ASSISTED OVER 2000 INDIVIDUALS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA ALONE IN THE
LAST 10 YEARS OVER 65% OF THEM
WERE FROM VULNERABLE. BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES. ALL REPORTED
A AT THE HANDS OF BUYERS,
INCLUDING RAPE, RAPE, COMBINED
WITH ROBBERY, RAPE, COMBINED
WITH BEATINGS AND ROBBERY,
STABBINGS BEING THROWN OUT OF
MOVING VEHICLES BEING HELD
HOSTAGE IN COUNTLESS INSTANCES
OF STRANGULATION AND RAPE, SELF
FANTASIES BEING PLAYED OUT. S¼ B
357, IN ADDITION TO INCREASING
BLATANT PHYSICAL ABUSE ON THE
STREETS ALSO REMOVED PROTECTIONS
AGAINST PERPETRATORS OF ABUSE BY
DECRIMINALIZING THE ACT OF
LOITERING FOR BUYERS AS WELL AS
PIMPS. FOR S¼ B, THREE 57 PIMPS
WERE LAID UP AT HOME ON A COUCH
WHILE THEY'RE 1213 1415 YEAR OLD
VICTIMS WERE WALKING THE STREETS
WITH BLOODY FEET. NOW THESE
PIMPS ARE LIBERATED TO STANDING
ON THE STREET CORNERS AND
KEEPING AN EVEN TIGHTER GRIP ON
THEIR VICTIMS WITHOUT ANY
REPERCUSSIONS. PIMP BUYERS AND
TRAFFICKERS ARE THE ONLY ONES
WHO BENEFITED FROM THREE 157,
MA'AM. TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. OUR NEXT LEAD WITNESS. YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. MY NAME IS
OPEL SINGLETON. I'M THE
PRESIDENT AND èC E Ó OF
MILLION KIDS WERE AN
ORGANIZATION THAT FOR 15 YEARS
NOW HAVE BEEN KEEPING KIDS SAFE
FROM PREDATORS. S¼ VÆ 357 HAS
HAD MANY UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
. ONE OF THOSE IS A MASSIVE
INCREASE IN THE AMOUNT OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING ACTIVITY TAKING
PLACE IN CALIFORNIA. THIS IS A
SERIOUS PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE, AND
WE NEED TO ADDRESS IT. I HAVE
PERSONALLY WITNESSED AFTER S¼ B
THREE 157 AND I'VE HEARD FROM
MANY CITY LEADERS AND MAYORS
ABOUT HOW PIMPS GANGS CARTELS
ARE BRINGING VAN LOADS OF GIRLS
IN FROM LAS VEGAS AND PHOENIX
AND ACROSS THE U S¼ A TO CONDUCT
COMMERCIAL SEXUAL SERVICES IN
OUR COMMUNITIES. MANY OF OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS HAVE LINES OF CARS
CRUISING UP AND DOWN THE STREETS
, STOPPING IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
ROAD TO NEGOTIATE A SEXUAL
TRANSACTION IN SAN DIEGO, L A
AND OAKLAND THE NEIGHBORHOODS
ARE NÓ LONGER. SAVE FOR CHILDREN
, FAMILIES OR ELDERLY. THERE ARE
USED CONDOMS, NEEDLES AND
CIGARETTES AND YARDS AND
DRIVEWAYS AND STREETS WHERE
THERE WERE ONCE CHILDREN THAT
WERE PLAYING TWO SCHOOLS IN THE
OAKLAND AREA HAVE BEEN FORCED TO
CLOSE BECAUSE IT IS NÓ LONGER
SAFE FOR PARENTS TO WALK THEIR
KIDS TO SCHOOL. DROP THEM OFF.
PARENTS HAVE TO CALL THE POLICE
AND ASK FOR AN ESCORT TO HAVE
THEIR CHILD BROUGHT FROM SCHOOL
THROUGH THE LINE OF SEX CELLAR.
PARENTS ARE AFRAID TO GET OUT OF
THEIR CAR TO GET THEIR KIDS
BECAUSE OF THREAT. FROM PARENTS.
I AM ESPECIALLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE HOMELESS. A HOMELESS WOMAN
IS A TRAFFICKED WOMAN. A
HOMELESS TEENAGER IS A TRAFFIC
TEENAGER, REGARDLESS OF GENDER
OR SEXUAL ORIENTATION. I CAN'T
IMAGINE THAT ANY OF YOU HAVE
CONSTITUENTS THAT WOULD HAVE
THEIR 13 YEAR OLD GIRL Dð STEP
OUT OF THEIR FRONT ROOM AND BE
GREETED BY A PIMP TRYING TO GET
HER IN THE LIFE OR HAVE YOUR
FIVE YEAR OLD GRANDDAUGHTER
ESCORTED FROM KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH SEX WORKERS JUST TO GET
TO THE CAR, BUT IT IS HAPPENING.
THANK YOU. I AM ASKING TO
APPROVE 12. SB 1219. THANK YOU,
UH, FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE A ME TOO COMMENT,
PLEASE. STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND THAT YOU
SUPPORT AND AGAIN LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO THAT YOU SUPPORT
AARON FRIDAY. PROTECT KIDS,
CALIFORNIA OUR DUTY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. HELEN TAYLOR WITH THE
ANTI TRAFFICKING ORGANIZATION.
EXODUS CRY, STANDING WITH
SURVIVORS IN SUPPORT. MADISON
MCQUEEN. ALSO WITH EXODUS CRY IN
SAN FRANCISCO RESIDENTS STRONG
SUPPORT. CIA. CRAVENS FORMER
CANDIDATE FOR CALIFORNIA STATE,
SENATE-DISTRICT 11, LONGTIME
DEMOCRAT VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF
THIS. YVETTE CORCORAN, LONGTIME
RESIDENT OF SAN FRANCISCO,
MOTHER NURSE VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF THIS. SO. POLY
JACKSON, FORMER TEENAGE RUNAWAY
IN SUPPORT. PEGGY DELGADO FAVA
BRIDGE NETWORK. WE PROVIDE
SERVICES FOR èC S¼ A, UH,
VICTIMS. THANK YOU SUPPORT. IVY
FITZPATRICK, CALIFORNIA G'S
ASSOCIATION, RIVERSIDE COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT. CRAIG BURT, WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. ROCHELLE CONNOR ON
BEHALF OF CONCERNED WOMEN FOR
AMERICA STRONG SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING LIEUTENANT JULIA DE LEÓN
OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT. DOING MASS
SAN BEIN COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT IN SUPPORT. HØI RANDY
PERRY OVER THERE AT READING
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF PAK AND
THE SAN FRANCISCO POLICE OFFICER
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER SUPPORT WITNESSES
OR ME, TOO, AS I SHOULD SAY.
NONE CAN WE MOVE ON TO, UM
OPPOSITION LEAD WITNESSES. EACH
OF YOU WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU. BECCA KRAMER MATTER
ON BEHALF OF A èC LU,
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THE COALITION TO
ABOLISH SLAVERY AND TRAFFICKING
CLIENT SERVICES DATA DOES NOT
SUPPORT THE CLAIM THAT S¼ B
THREE 157 HAS INCREASED RATES OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING OR STREET
BASED SEX WORK. IN FACT, IN L, A
COUNTY THEY HAVE SEEN A DECREASE
IN HOTLINE AND MEET EMERGENCY
RESPONSE CALLS SINCE 2021 AND TO
THE EXTENT THAT THERE MAY BE AN
INCREASE IN STREET BASED SEX
TRADE, MANY THINGS COULD
CONTRIBUTE TO THIS POTENTIAL
RISE, INCLUDING RISING HOUSING
COSTS THE REDUCTION OF COVID
RELATED FINANCIAL RELIEF
PROGRAMS AND SHIFTING LABOR
LAWS. SEX WORKERS ARE OFTEN
PARENTS WORKING TO SUPPORT THEIR
CHILDREN AND RATES OF SURVIVAL.
SEX WORK WOULD BE GREATLY
REDUCED BY ADDRESSING THE
HOUSING CRISIS AND BUILDING A
STRONGER SOCIAL SAFETY NETWORK.
ARRESTING SEX WORKERS FOR
LOITERING DOES NOT HELP ANYONE.
IT ONLY HIDES PEOPLE FROM VIEW
AND MAKES ALL SEX WORKERS,
INCLUDING THOSE WHO ARE
TRAFFICKED, MORE VULNERABLE TO
VIOLENCE AND ABUSE. CAST
RECENTLY CONDUCTED A STATEWIDE
SURVEY OF PRACTITIONERS WHO
SERVE PEOPLE WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING,
SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND OF THEIR
RESPONDENTS, THE OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY HAD SEEN CLIENTS WHO
HAD BEEN PREVIOUSLY ARRESTED OR
DETAINED AND REPORTED THAT MORE
THAN HALF OF THEM REPORTED THAT
BEING ARRESTED OR DETAINED HAD
MADE SURVIVAL MORE VULNERABLE TO
VICTIMIZATION, AND ONE THIRD
REPORTED THAT THEIR CLIENTS HAD
BEEN VICTIMIZED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT. ADDITIONALLY LAWS
AIMED AT CRIMINALIZING
PURCHASERS OF SEX CREATE MORE
DANGEROUS WORKING CONDITIONS FOR
SEX WORKERS AND PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRAFFICKED. SIMILAR LAWS IN
OTHER COUNTRIES HAVE PUSHED SEX
WORKERS TO OPERATE UNDER RISKIER
CONDITIONS WITH HARMFUL
IMPLICATIONS FOR THEIR HEALTH,
INCLUDING A DECREASE IN CONDOM
USE AND INCREASED DRUG AND
ALCOHOL USE, DEPRESSION AND
SUICIDAL THOUGHTS AND VIOLENCE
AGAINST SEX WORKERS. RESULTS
LIKE THESE, INCLUDING THE
HARMFUL IMPACT ON VICTIMS OF SEX
TRAFFICKING, HAVE LED AMNESTY
INTERNATIONAL TO RECOMMEND THAT
SOME OF THESE LAWS IN OTHER
COUNTRIES BE REPEALED.
INCREASING. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. TWO MINUTES. HØI UM MY NAME
IS FATIMA MALIKA SHABAZZ. HERE
ON BEHALF OF DEM SEX WORK,
CALIFORNIA WE WROTE S¼ B THREE
57 ADMITTEDLY, YES, THERE IS A
PROBLEM WITH, UH SEX
TRAFFICKING. WE KNOW THIS. THIS
BILL, HOWEVER, IS BAD POLICY.
THIS BILL DOES NOT HELP ANYONE.
WHAT IT DOES IS INCREASED. IT
INCREASES THE ABILITY FOR SEX
WORKERS TO BE HARMED. UM
STATISTICS SHOW THAT THERE'S NOT
MAYBE TWO OUT OF THREE. MAYBE
FOUR PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY GET
HELPED OR WHO ARE SEX TRAFFICKED
AND THEY GET HELP. UM WHEN THEY
ARE ARRESTED, BUT BEING ARRESTED
IS A TRAUMATIC INCIDENT. IT IS
VIOLENT. IT IS. HORRIBLE TO
PEOPLE IT PUTS THEM IN. HE PUTS
THEM AT RISK IN AND OUT RIGHT.
IT MAKES HIS JOB WHICH IS
ALREADY A VERY, VERY DANGEROUS
JOB. IT PUT THESE PEOPLE IN MORE
VULNERABLE POSITIONS. THE BILLS
LIKE THIS ARE BAD POLICY, AND
THEY KILL PEOPLE OUTRIGHT. THEY
KILL PEOPLE. YOU KNOW BE THEY,
UM, A PERSON WHO HAS SEX
TRAFFICKED OR JUST YOUR AVERAGE,
ONE OF THE MOST STREET WORKER
WHO WAS JUST TRYING TO TAKE CARE
OF THEIR FAMILIES PAY BILLS,
JUST LIKE EVERYONE ELSE IN THIS
ROOM. YOU KNOW, THIS BILL IS BAD
POLICY. IT KILLS PEOPLE. THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES. OAKLAND
STATISTICS SHOW THAT AS WE DO,
57 DID NOT INCREASE STREET BASED
SEX WORK. AND IT DIDN'T RIGHT.
IF ANYTHING, IT DID A 205 DID.
BUT THIS BILL WILL NOT. I
GUARANTEE YOU IT WILL NOT HELP
ANYONE BEING SEX TRAFFICKED I. I
REALLY HAVE A WHOLE LOT OF
EMPATHY AND SYMPATHY FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO GO THROUGH THAT AND
THERE IS A PROBLEM. IT NEEDS TO
BE RESOLVED. BUT THIS BILL IS
NOT THE WAY TO DO IT. THIS BILL
IS ONLY GONNA GET PEOPLE HURT.
IT'S ONLY GONNA GET PEOPLE
KILLED. THAT'S GONNA BE THE
BOTTOM LINE TO THAT. PEOPLE WILL
GET HURT. PEOPLE WILL GET KILLED
AND NÓ ONE WILL BE HELPED. SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU, UH, WE WILL MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION. ME TOOS, PLEASE,
STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND THAT YOU OPPOSE
THIS BILL. GOOD MORNING. GLENN
BACKUS FOR SMART JUSTICE,
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION. LESLIE
CALDWELL, HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE IN OPPOSITION. BARBARA
CHÁVEZ WITH THE ELLA BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS STRONGLY
OPPOSE. GOOD MORNING, TATIANA
LEWIS WITH THE ELLA BAKER CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS AND STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. CRAIG PUL
ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY.
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION ALSO
OPPOSED SWAP L, A THE COALITION
TO ABOLISH SLAVERY AND
TRAFFICKING FREE SPEECH
COALITION AND THE CENTER ON
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS AND JUSTICE.
KATHY MOSSBERG ON BEHALF OF ÁP
L, A HEALTH AND SAN FRANCISCO
GREATS FOUNDATION BOTH OPPOSED.
SYMPHONY BARBIE ON BEHALF OF
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION. MOAR
HERE ON BEHALF OF LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS OR CHILDREN. ALL
OF US ARE NOT IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. TOMORROW ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN OPPOSITION.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER OPPOSITION
WITNESSES SEEING NONE. WE WILL
MOVE THE CONVERSATION TO MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. SENATOR
WEINER. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR
AND THANK YOU, SENATOR FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION TODAY. UM UH, THINK
PROBABLY SURPRISES NÓ ONE. I'M
NOT GOING TO BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL TODAY. THE AUTHOR OF S¼ B.
UH THREE 57. WE INTRODUCED THAT
BILL IN ADVANCE TO AND THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED IT FOR VERY
SPECIFIC REASON. THIS IS NOT THE
LOITERING LAW THAT S¼ B 357
REPEAL WAS NOT YOUR TYPICAL
CRIMINAL LAW THAT IF YOU DO X.
THAT IS A CRIME AND YOU ARE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT CRIME. THIS
IS LITERALLY ONE OF THE MORE
PERNICIOUS KINDS OF CRIMINAL
LAWS THAT IF YOU'RE SIMPLY
STANDING AROUND, DRESSED IN A
CERTAIN WAY, YOUR HAIR IS IN A
CERTAIN WAY. YOUR MAKEUP IS IN A
CERTAIN WAY. IF AN OFFICER IS
SUBJECTIVELY THINKS THAT'S
SOMEONE WHO I THINK IS ENGAGING
IN SEX WORK. UH THEY CAN ARREST
YOU, UM, I. I FIND THAT KIND OF
CRIME TO BE OFFENSIVE AND THAT'S
WHY WE REPEALED IT AND I
UNDERSTAND NOT EVERYONE AGREES
WITH ME. UM AND I RESPECT THAT.
BUT THAT'S MY PERSPECTIVE. I DO
WANNA, HOWEVER, JUST SAY SOME OF
THE UH, WHAT SORT OF NARRATIVE
AROUND S¼ P 357 IS, UH, IS JUST
BLATANTLY FALSE. AND I SAY THIS
AS SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN AROUND
US AND INVOLVED WITH IT FOR A
FEW YEARS NOW, UM I WILL SAY
THAT JUST TO GIVE YOU SOME
EXAMPLES, EVEN BEFORE EVEN
BEFORE THIS LAW WENT INTO EFFECT
, THERE WERE POLICE WHO WERE
TELLING THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THERE'S NOTHING WE CAN DO
BECAUSE OF S¼ THREE 157 BEFORE
IT WAS EVEN IN EFFECT, WHILE THE
LOITERING LAW WAS STILL ON THE
BOOKS THAT HAPPENED IN MY OWN
CITY. A PARTICULAR CAPTAIN AT
MISSION STATION BECAUSE WE HAVE
SOME PARTS OF THE MISSION THAT
ARE VERY IMPACTED BY STREET
PROSTITUTION, AND THOSE
NEIGHBORS SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
DEAL WITH WHAT THEY HAVE TO DO
WITH WHAT THEY ARE OFTEN DEALING
WITH, AND THE CITY HAS EMPLOYED
VARIOUS STRATEGIES, UM TO
ADDRESS IT FOR DECADES, YOU CAN
FIND CHRONICLE ARTICLES FROM THE
19 NINETIES TALKING ABOUT, UH,
THE PROBLEMS WITH STREET
PROSTITUTION IN THIS PART OF THE
MISSION, AND YET, THE CAPTAIN
ANNOUNCED TO NEIGHBORS. IT'S
BECAUSE S¼ B 357, WHICH WAS NOT
EVEN AN EFFECT YET, BECAUSE
THAT'S WHY THIS IS HAPPENING.
EVEN THOUGH IT WAS HAPPENING IN
THE 19 NINETIES. IT WAS
HAPPENING BEFORE THE LORD CRIME
WAS CREATED. IT WAS HAPPENING
DURING THE DECADES OF THAT CRIME
WAS ON THE AND IT CONTINUES. UM
SO IT WAS ALSO THE CASE THAT SAN
FRANCISCO STOPPED ENFORCING THAT
LOITERING LAW YEARS AGO. AND YET
YOU HAVE POLICE TELLING
MISLEADING. FRANKLY THIS ONE
CAPTAIN MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT THIS LAW THAT WE STOPPED
ENFORCING YEARS AGO. THAT IT'S
REPEAL OF THE LAW. WE DIDN'T
EVEN ENFORCE OR UTILIZE. THAT'S
WHY THIS IS HAPPENING. IT WAS
MADE UP. WE ALSO SAW A
PARTICULARLY OUTRAGEOUS EXAMPLE
IN THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO. UM
AFTER S¼ P THREE, 57 WAS IN
EFFECT TO THE LOITERING LAW WAS
OFF THE BOOKS. THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO AND THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO. THE Dð A THE STATE
FEDERAL. THEY DID A BIG JOINT
OPERATION TO ADDRESS THE
DESPICABLE CRIME OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. THEY DID A BIG
OPERATION THEY ARRESTED. I DON'T
REMEMBER THE EXACT NUMBER. IT
WAS LIKE 40 OR 50 TRAFFICKERS.
THEY ARRESTED AND THEY RESCUED.
I BELIEVE SOMETHING LIKE 15 OR
20 YOUNG WOMEN WHO WERE BEING
TRAFFICKED. THEY DID ALL OF
THAT, EVEN THOUGH THE LOITERING
LAW HAD BEEN REPEALED. THEY DID
A BIG, CELEBRATORY PRESS
CONFERENCE, AS THEY SHOULD HAVE
BY ARRESTING THESE HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS AND RESCUING THESE
YOUNG WOMEN. AND THEY CELEBRATED
THIS REALLY IMPORTANT THING THAT
THEY DID. AND THEN THE I CAN'T
REMEMBER. I THINK IT WAS THE
POLICE CHIEF, AND MAYBE THE Dð A
TWO GOT UP AND SAID, BY THE WAY,
S¼ B THREE, 57 HAS HANDCUFFED US
AND ELIMINATED OUR ABILITY TO
DEAL WITH HUMAN TRAFFICKING AS
THEY WERE ANNOUNCING THAT THE
ARREST OF DOZENS OF TRAFFICKERS
SO I UNDERSTAND THERE'S A LOT OF
POLITICS AROUND THIS ISSUE, AND
WE HAVE A LONG STANDING PROBLEM
THAT HAS EXISTED SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF PROBLEM ISSUE. SOME
PEOPLE VIEW IT THAT WAY. SOME
PEOPLE DON'T UH, AN ISSUE THAT
HAS BEEN AROUND FROM THE
BEGINNING OF THE HUMAN SPECIES.
AND PEOPLE GET FRUSTRATED BY
THAT, AND THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
ABUSE OTHER PEOPLE AND SHOULD BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND PEOPLE WHO
ARE TRAFFICKING. OTHER PEOPLE
SHOULD BE HARSHLY PUNISHED. AND
THERE'S ALWAYS THIS DESIRE.
LET'S FIND A SCAPEGOAT. UH AND
LET'S BLAME THE LEGISLATURE. YOU
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS THE TOOLS
THAT THEY NEED TO ARREST
TRAFFICKERS TO RESCUE
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS AND TO
ENFORCE THE LAW. YOU DON'T NEED
A VAGUE, LOITERING LAW THAT
LEADS TO ABSOLUTELY ARBITRARY
AND DISCRIMINATORY. ENFORCEMENT
SO I DON'T I DON'T SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU, SENATOR. SEEING
NÓ OTHER COMMENTS. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? UM HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IS MODERN DAY
SLAVERY. THAT'S WHAT IT IS. AND
I THINK WE ARE ALL WE'VE HEARD
OVER AND OVER. ABOUT THE ILLS OF
SLAVERY. UM, IN 2020 ALONE.
THREE 100,000 VICTIMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING WERE IDENTIFIED IN
THE U S¼. WOMEN AND GIRLS. WERE
FOUND TO BE PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE. AFRICAN AMERICAN
WOMEN ARE DISPROPORTIONATE,
DISPROPORTIONATELY AT HIGHER
RISK. WITH MANY WOMEN REPORTING
SEXUAL ABUSE, BEATINGS, FOOD AND
SLEEP DEPRIVATION, ISOLATION
FROM THE OUTSIDE WORLD. RESEARCH
FROM THE U S¼ STATE DEPARTMENT
AND A LARGE BODY OF SCIENTIFIC
RESEARCH HAS FOUND A CLOSE
CONNECTION BETWEEN THE
PROSTITUTION. AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
THAT THE DECRIMINALIZATION OF
PROSTITUTION HAS NOT LED TO
BETTER SAFEGUARDS FOR VICTIMS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING, AND THAT
RECENTLY THERE HAS BEEN AN
EXPLOSION OF UNDERAGE
POPULATION. AND THIS IS BECAUSE
OF THE CONFLUENCE OF OUR
DYNAMICS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
TODAY WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
COMING INTO OUR COUNTRY. UM AND
A LOT OF THEM ARE UNDERAGE
PEOPLE AND THOSE PEOPLE ARE
BEING EXPLOITED. AND THEY'RE NOT
BEING EXPLOITED BY THE PERSON
DOWN THE STREET THAT DECIDED
THAT THEY WERE GOING TO BE A
PIMP. THESE ARE BEING EXPLOITED
BY VERY SOPHISTICATED CRIMINAL
ENTERPRISES. WHAT THIS LAW IS
SUPPOSED TO DO. IS REAL BACK
WHAT WE'VE SEEN AS THE AND I
DON'T KNOW IF IT UNINTENTIONAL
CONSEQUENCES, BUT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THE BILL FROM
LAST YEAR. AND I UNDERSTAND THE
INTENT OF NOT BOTHERING PEOPLE
THAT WANT TO BE ENGAGED IN THIS
AND THAT THE PEOPLE ARE MAKING
MONEY. THIS BILL IS TO TRY TO
HELP VICTIMS. ITS FOCUSED ON THE
VICTIMS AND THE ABILITY OF OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY. TO BE
ABLE TO HELP. GET THOSE VICTIMS
OUT OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
THEY'RE IN SAFELY. I MEAN
SAFELY. BECAUSE IF WE DON'T DO
THAT, IF WE DON'T ALLOW THEM
THAT SAFE EXIT FROM THIS WORLD
THEY'LL BE TRAPPED IN IT
FOREVER. AND THE CYCLE THAT THEY
ARE IN WILL CONTINUE. WITH THEIR
FAMILIES. FOLKS, WE CAN'T STAND
BY. AND WATCH THE CONSEQUENCES
OF A BILL AND THAT'S WHAT YOU
KNOW FOR ME. I'M I'M ALL FOR
WHEN THEY BILL PASSES. OK LET'S
SEE HOW IT WORKS. BUT THIS
PARTICULAR BILL WHEN YOU START
SEEING HOW IT IS WORKING AND
WHAT THE NEGATIVE EFFECTS ARE,
YOU BETTER DARN WELL GET OUT
THERE AHEAD OF IT. WELL, YOU'RE
NOT AHEAD OF IT ANYMORE, BUT GET
OUT THERE AND DO SOMETHING. YOU
CAN'T WAIT FOR LONGITUDINAL
STUDIES OF FIVE YEARS TO
DETERMINE WHAT KIND OF DAMAGE
AND HOW MANY PEOPLE IT GOT
KILLED. YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
PEOPLE GETTING KILLED. YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT KIDS GETTING
EXPLOITED AND RUINING THEIR
LIVES FOR THE REST OF THEIR
LIVES. THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT
NEED TO BE HELPED OUT. THIS LAW
HAS NOT ENABLED. THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN GENERAL TO BE
ABLE TO EVEN HELP THOSE PEOPLE.
SO THE PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY
STUDY THIS HAVE BEEN OUT THERE.
THEY'VE SEEN IT. THEY'VE
ACTUALLY WALKED THOSE STREETS.
THEY'VE SEEN THE INCREASE SINCE
THIS BILL PASSED. AND THAT'S WHY
THEY ARE IMPLORING US TO DO
SOMETHING. AND SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS WE'RE
TRYING TO DO SOMETHING. DO
SOMETHING FOR THE VICTIMS. THE
PEOPLE THAT DON'T WANT TO BE
TRAPPED IN THAT WORLD. THE TWO
PEOPLE WHO DON'T WANT TO BE
EXPLOITED ANYMORE. AND SO THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL IS FOCUSED ON
THAT IS TRYING TO DO THERE ARE
SECTIONS OF THIS BILL THAT TALK
ABOUT THE PEOPLE THAT MAKE THE
MOST MONEY IN THIS. THE PEOPLE
AT THE TOP. IS LIKE THE
CORPORATIONS I HEAR ABOUT A LOT
OF PEOPLE COMPLAIN THE
CORPORATION. THE PEOPLE AT THE
TOP ARE MAKING ALL THE MONEY AND
THE POOR PEOPLE AT THE BOTTOM.
DON'T GET ANYTHING. THIS IS NÓ
DIFFERENT. BUT HERE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE DYING. THAT
DON'T WANT TO BE IN THIS WORLD.
AND WE'RE NOT DOING ANYTHING FOR
HIM. BECAUSE WE'RE AFRAID OF
DOING SOMETHING. WE'RE AFRAID OF
INCONVENIENCING THE PEOPLE THAT
YOU WANT. AND THE LAST THING IS
BEING A PIMP BEING A JOHN AND
PROSTITUTION. IT'S CURRENTLY
ILLEGAL. SUPPORTING THE ILLEGAL
ACTIVITIES. AND AS A AND IN
SAYING THAT WE SHOULDN'T BE
HELPING VICTIMS BECAUSE THOSE
PEOPLE WILL BE INCONVENIENCE. IT
IS A HORRIBLE ARGUMENT. SO THIS
BILL. I WISH IT WOULD PASS, BUT
I KNOW IT'S NOT GOING TO AND THE
ONLY PERSON THAT'S GOING TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE THE MOTION IS ME.
AND SO I'M GOING TO DO THAT. I
WILL MAKE THE MOTION FOR THIS
BILL. YOU CAN'T TECHNICALLY AS
THE AUTHOR AND A MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE WHEN THERE'S ONLY TWO
PEOPLE HERE. YOU CAN'T MAKE NOT
ON YOUR BILL. OK? THEN I WOULD
LEAVE IT UP TO MY, UH, BOARD
MEMBERS HERE. TO AT LEAST HAVE
THE DECENCY TO HAVE A MOTION ON
THIS BILL SO WE CAN TAKE A VOTE
AND WE CAN PUT IT ON THE RECORD.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, UM ANY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WHO ARE
HERE. ALL RIGHT, SEEING NÓ
MOTION. WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY. WE HAVE TWO MEMBERS
OUT. UM SO WE THERE IS A ROLL
CALL THAT'S STILL OPEN. UM, WE
CAN WAIT. WE WILL MOVE ON TO OUR
NEXT BILL. UM SENATOR WEINER S¼.
B 905. THIS IS OUR FINAL BILL.
SIX. WHAT IS IT? PROSTATE.
THANKS. I THINK YEAH. THIS. LAW
IS YOURS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MADAM CHAIR. UM TODAY I'M
PRESENTING SENATE BILL 905,
WHICH CLOSES THE LOCKED DOOR
LOOPHOLE A NONSENSICAL BARRIER
TO HOLDING AUTO BURGLARS
ACCOUNTABLE. I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH US. UM HAPPY TO
ACCEPT, UH, THE, UM, AMENDMENTS
THAT WE WORKED OUT WITH THE
COMMITTEE. UH, THESE AMENDMENTS
WERE MADE IN CONSULTATION WITH
THE COMMITTEE AT MY REQUESTS AND
THEY ARE AS FOLLOWS. THE FIRST
AMENDMENT COMBINES TWO SECTIONS
OR TWO SUBSECTIONS IN SECTION
ONE OF THE BILL WITH THE INTENT
OF AMELIORATING POTENTIAL
IMMIGRATION CONSEQUENCES WITHOUT
IMPACTING THE SUBSTANCE OF THE
BILL AT ALL. THE SECOND ENSURES
SECTION TWO DOES NOT PRECLUDE OR
PROHIBIT PROSECUTION ANY OTHER
UNDER ANY OTHER EXISTING PENAL
CODE STATUTE. UM AND I'M
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK,
UH, WITH, UH, ADVOCATES ON THIS
BILL RELATING TO OTHER CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED. UM UNDER
EXISTING LAW IN ORDER TO PROVE
THE CRIME OF AUTO BURGLARY. THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY MUST PROVE
THAT AN OFFENDER BROKE THE
WINDOW IN ORDER TO GAIN ENTRY.
UM AND HOW THEY ALSO MUST. I'M
SORRY. LET ME START THAT OVER
AGAIN UNDER EXISTING LAW IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE A BURGLARY THAT
THIS ATTORNEY HAS TO PROVE THAT
THE DOOR WAS LOCKED. THIS IS
RIDICULOUS, EVEN IF YOU HAVE
EVIDENCE THAT THERE WAS FORCIBLE
ENTRY, A PROSECUTION CAN FAIL
BECAUSE, FOR EXAMPLE, SOMEONE
DOESN'T REMEMBER THAT THEY
LOCKED THE DOOR. UH OR, UH, YOU
HAVE A TOURIST WITH A RENTAL CAR
WHO'S THREE 1000 MILES AWAY AND
NOT COMING BACK, SO WE NEED TO
CLOSE THAT LOOPHOLE. IT MAKES
NÓ. AND WE ALSO HAVE INCLUDED
PROVISIONS IN THERE, WORKING IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE GOVERNOR
AND WITH OUR LEADERSHIP RELATING
TO THE RESALE OF ITEMS STOLEN
FROM CARS AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE TIGHTENING UP THAT ASPECT
OF THE LAW WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE
WITH ME TO TESTIFY AS CARL FROM
SAN FRANCISCO POLICE DEPARTMENT.
THANK YOU. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
GOOD MORNING. PRINCIPAL
LEGISLATIVE LIAISON FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO POLICE DEPARTMENT,
FIRST, THANKS TO SENATOR WEINER
FOR HIS SUPPORT AND WORK ON THIS
ISSUE, AS I'M SURE, YOU KNOW,
CAR BREAK INS ARE A PERSISTENT
PROBLEM IN SAN FRANCISCO ARE
CITY IS MAKING REAL PROGRESS TO
DISRUPT AUTO BREAK INS, THANKS
TO THE VERY HARD WORK OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
POLICE DEPARTMENT, BUT WE NEED
MORE TOOLS TO SUSTAIN THIS WORK.
ONE CHALLENGE WITH AUTO BREAK
INS IS THE LOCKED DOOR LOOPHOLE.
AS SENATOR WEINER JUST SAID,
UNDER CURRENT LAW TO SECURE A
CONVICTION. AUTO BURGLAR IS
ARRESTED. ONE OF THE ELEMENTS
THAT PROSECUTORS MUST PROVE IS
THAT THE VEHICLE WAS LOCKED A
VICTIM BROKEN WINDOW BY ITSELF
DOES NOT ESTABLISH THAT THE
VEHICLE WAS LOCKED. AS A RESULT,
VICTIMS ARE OFTEN ASKED TO
TESTIFY IN COURT THAT THEIR
VEHICLE WAS LOCKED. BUT WHEN A
VICTIM IS A TOURIST OR A
VISITOR, AS IS OFTEN THE CASE IN
SAN FRANCISCO, IT CAN BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO SECURE THE
TESTIMONY OF A VICTIM BECAUSE
THEY LIVE ELSEWHERE. SENATE BILL
NINE AND FIVE, SPONSORED BY SAN
FRANCISCO MAYOR LONDON. BREED
CLOSES THIS LOCKED DOOR LOOPHOLE
CLOSING THE LOOPHOLE WILL HELP
PROSECUTE THE ORGANIZED THEFT
RINGS THEFT RINGS TARGETING SAN
FRANCISCO, ESPECIALLY IN OUR
TOURIST AREAS. MORE SUCCESSFUL
PROSECUTIONS OF THESE CASES WILL
SEND A MESSAGE THAT IF YOU BREAK
INTO CARS, YOU WILL BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AGAIN. THANKS TO
SENATOR WEINER FOR HIS WORK ON
THIS ISSUE. THANKS FOR YOUR TIME
THIS MORNING, AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS, PAUL, YOU ARE ON
BEHALF OF MARY LYNN AND BREED IN
THE CITY AND COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MAX PERRY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
POLICE CHIEF ASSOCIATION, ALSO
IN SUPPORT. RANDY PERRY, THE
BETTER LOOKING ONE. REPRESENTING
PAK, THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HIGHER PATROLMEN IN SAN
FRANCISCO. P A IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ETHAN LARM HAD THE CITY OF
CARLSBAD IN SUPPORT. IVY
FITZPATRICK, CALIFORNIA DAS
ASSOCIATION, RIVERSIDE COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND
SUPPORT KILLING OF OR ON BEHALF
OF THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES AND SPORT. RIGHT, AND I'M
BACK TO THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. AMELIA
ZAMANI, WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TRAVEL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
ANTHONY BUTLER TORRES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HISPANIC CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND SUPPORT YOU. NÓ
OTHER SUPPORT. WITNESSES WILL
MOVE ON TO LEAD OPPOSITION. SEE
NONE. OK, GO AHEAD. OK? UM I
GUESS WE'RE TWEENERS. LESLIE
CALDWELL, HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION. WE THANK SENATOR
WEINER AND HIS STAFF ARE WORKING
WITH US SO CLOSELY ON THIS, WE
STILL HAVE SOME ISSUES. UM, SO
WE'RE NOT WITHDRAWING OPPOSITION
ALTOGETHER, BUT WE DO. THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH US SEEING NÓ
OTHER OPPOSITION WITNESSES. WE
WILL MOVE ON TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SENATOR MOVES THE
BILL. SENATOR, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I
VOTE. THANK YOU, UM LET'S DO A
ROLL CALL. 905 MOTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WAH WAH I SAY ART
TOTO I. BRADFORD SKINNER WIENER.
WE ARE. I THAT BILL IS ON CALL.
WE HAVE TWO MEMBERS WE ARE
WAITING FOR TO LIFT THE CALL. UM
I APPRECIATE EVERYBODY. UM AND
LET'S CALL OUR MEMBERS BACK TO
THE ROOM. WE'RE TRYING TO GET ON
BRADFORD'S PRESENTING TWO BILLS.
I'LL LET YOU GO. LET'S LIFT THE
CALL. S¼ B 902. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE TO ZERO. WEINER WEINER. I
Tð S¼ B 921. THE MOTION IS DUE
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE
THREE ZERO WIENER WIENER, I
CONSENT CALENDAR. WIENER WIENER.
I SP 1035 MOTION IS DUE PASS TO
REVIN TAX CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 1
WIENER WIENER. I. YEAH S¼ P 1242
TO PASS TWO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE 3 TO 0 WIENER
WIENER. I 1253 MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE 2 TO 1 WIENER
WIENER. I.
RELIGIOUS UH, HOLD ON A MINUTE.
PUT MY GLASSES ON. GLASS ROOM.
THEN I WILL BE READY. OK, SO WE
GO THROUGH.
ALL RIGHT. FOR SENATE PUBLIC
SAFETY. LET'S LIFT THE CALL,
PLEASE. S¼ VÆ 902. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS 4
TO 0. SKINNER SKINNER. I THAT
OUT THAT OUT THAT BILL IS OUT.
EXCUSE ME. S¼ VÆ 921 CURRENT OR
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE 4 TO
0 SKINNER SKINNER. CONSENT
CALENDAR. SKINNER HØI SKINNER.
AYE.
ALL THAT 1219 MOTION IS DUE PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS. WHICH ONE
NEEDS A MOTION WHICH 119
.
S¼ P, NINE AND FIVE. MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE TO ZERO. SKINNER. GET THAT
PAGE. FIVE SKIN OR EYE.
ALL RIGHT. UH, WE WILL LIFT THE
CALL. S¼ 902 HAS BEEN DISPENSED
WITH, AS HAS S¼ B 921. THAT BILL
IS OUT. THE SENATE HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH CONSENT IS OUT.
S¼ P 1035 MOTION IS TO PASS TO
REV AND TAX CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE TO ONE. BRADFORD BRADFORD.
AYE, THAT BILL IS OUT. SB 1069
MOTION IS DUE PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
4 TO 0 BRADFORD BRADFORD I THAT
BILL IS OUT. SB 1242. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0 BRADFORD
BRADFORD. THAT BILL IS OUT. S¼ B
1250 THREE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 1 BRADFORD
BRADFORD IY THAT BILL IS OUT.
AND S¼ B 905 ACTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0 BRADFORD.
UH, BRADFORD HØI THAT BILL IS
OUT. SO S¼ B 1219 NEEDS A
MOTION. HEALTH. SO UM S¼ B 1219
IS HELD IN COMMITTEE. I WANT TO
MAKE IT VERY CLEAR THAT AS CHAIR
I CANNOT MAKE A MOTION ON ANY
BILL AND OTHER THAN THAT, I
BELIEVE THAT THE SENATE PUBLIC
SAFETY IS ADJOURNED. THANK YOU.